COURSE SO WE WILL BUILD A CAST
VOTES BUT I HAVE THERE ARE A LOT
OF BUSY THINGS HAPPENING ALL
OVER THE COUPLE TODAY SO I THINK
IT'S BEST THAT WE JUST GET
STARTED.
SO.
WITH THAT I SEE ARE THE CENTER
MORALE HERE IN YOUR EYES.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A CENTER
BECAUSE WE ARE SO LET'S LET'S
ASK GENERAL COME UP PRESENT ITEM
TO THIS IS SB.
THREE EIGHTY FOUR WELL WE DON OF
OKAY WE'LL CALL WE'LL CALL
ATTENDANCE AND ALLEN HERE ALLEN
HERE BATES.
BATES PRESENT HELLO.
SKINNER STERN.
TONE I CASCADE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT
WE HOPEFULLY WILL SOON.
THE CENTER MORALE -- IS HERE TO
PRESENT ITEM TWO IN YOUR PACKETS
MEMBERS SP.
THREE EIGHTY FOUR I'M ACTUALLY
IN HOUSING.
MAYBE SEE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GIVE ME ANOTHER TWENTY MINUTES.
YEAH IF YOU WERE WITH YOU ALSO
I'M JUST A MAJOR JOKE OKAY I
GUESS I FUNNY ONE ALL RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY REMEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SP THREE
EIGHTY FOUR PROPOSES A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH TO FIXING
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS.
FIRST DOES TWO THINGS IT
STREAMLINES THE SICK WORK
PROCESS FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
OF FIFTY UNITS ARE MORE
ACCORDING THIS SAME PROCESS THIS --
LEGISLATURE HAS USED ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS THE X. BY -- TO SPEED
UP -- SPORTS ARENAS.
AND INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF
CAPITAL GAINS TAX FILERS CAN
EXCLUDE.
UP FROM THERE.
STATE INCOME TAX REMOTE -- FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE SEQUEL
COMPONENTS OF MY BILL TODAY SO I
WILL FOCUS ON TESTIMONY THERE.
WE ARE ALL AWARE THE CALIFORNIA
DOES FACE A HOUSING CRISIS
ACCORDING APARTMENT HOUSING.
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WE
HAVE AN ANNUAL PRODUCTION
SHORTFALL OF NEARLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES MEDIUM HOME
PRICES HERE IN CALIFORNIA NOW.
HAVE DOUBLE THAT OF THE AVERAGE
PRICE IS -- ACROSS AMERICA WERE
WERE RIGHT AT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND WE ALSO HAVE -- THE
THIRD LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE.
IN BROWN.
THE COUNTRY COMPOUNDING THIS
PROBLEM IS THE SEQUEL PROCESS
WHICH HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED BY
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE AS A
ROADBLOCK -- TO DEVELOPMENT --
WE CAN ALL AGREE I BELIEVE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS THE INTENT
OF SEQUEL -- BUT TOO OFTEN IT'S
SIMPLY USE TO DELAYED
DEVELOPMENT ALL TOGETHER WHICH
IS WHY THE LAW.
AND PROCESS NEED SIGNIFICANT
REFORMS -- THE LEGISLATION
REFORM SEEMS TO BE OUT OF REACH
THE LEGISLATURE HAS REPEATEDLY
SPED UP THE JUDICIAL PROCESS.
FOR HIGH PROFILE PROJECTS LIKE
SPORTING ARENAS WHICH I HAVE
SUPPORTED HOWEVER WE CAN TAKE
THAT ACTION WHY NOT DO SO FOR
MUCH NEEDED RESIDENTIAL UNITS
THEY GET TIED DOWN AND LIKELY --
EXPENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
OUR LAWSUITS IT'S CLEARLY A BI
PARTISAN POSITION AND SO WHAT SP
THREE EIGHTY FOUR DOES AS
FOLLOWS THE GOVERNOR'S CALL --
IN HIS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
STATE OF THE STATE SPEECH IN
WHICH HE SAID IN RECENT YEARS --
BASICALLY SAYS WE NEED TO SPEED
UP THE SEQUEL PROCESS FOR
PROFESSIONAL SPORTING IT'S TIME
WE DO THE SAME THING. FOR
HOUSING AND AND I JUST WANT TO
ADD ON THAT TOO IN OUR YOUNGER
GENERATION ONE OF THE HIGHEST --
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT ARE LEAVING
OUR STATE ARE HIGHLY EDUCATED
YOUNG PROFESSIONALS BETWEEN THE
AGES OF TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
NINE AND ONE REASON IS -- F.
HOUSING VERY EXPENSIVE
CALIFORNIA SO ANYWAY -- THREE
EIGHTY FOUR IS A STRAIGHT
FORWARD STEP -- WE CAN TAKE TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND IT WILL
INSURE EQUAL TREATMENT UNDER THE
LAW FOR SICK WELL WAIVERS ON
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS WITH FIFTY
OR MORE UNITS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR HIGH
BOTH HIS HELP STREAMLINE
DEVELOPMENT SO WE CAN BEGIN TO
BUILD.
HOUSING OUR CONSTITUENTS WANT
AND NEED AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE D. AS
CASSIE GILSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA -- BUILDING INDUSTRY.
HEY KATHY HI.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE FLY IN A LOT
OF COMMITTEES THIS MORNING.
I AM.
THE AUTHOR IS BRINGING FORWARD
AN ISSUE.
THAT WE TALK ABOUT INFORMALLY
ALL THE TIME WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW WE SEE A SERIES OF I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF THEM A STADIUM
BILLS.
THEY SOMETIMES APPLIED TO OTHER
THINGS.
WE ARE WE DO.
LITIGATION SEEK WITH
STREAMLINING.
THE QUESTION IS A FOUR WHEEL
BEFORE PREPARED TO ADMIT THAT.
DOES MAKE A PROJECTS NEED SOME
STREAMLINING IN THEIR SICKLE
REVIEW -- WHEN WE HAD A HOUSING
CRISIS OF THE MAGNITUDE THAT I
THINK THAT ANALYSIS LAYS OUT
WELL?
WHY WOULDN'T WE CONSIDER DOING
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT -- FOR
HOUSING -- THE A COMMENT ON A
COUPLE OF ISSUES IN IN THE
ANALYSIS THE FIRST IS I THINK WE
OFTEN FRAMED THIS DEBATE -- IN A
MANNER THAT'S TOO HYPERBOLIC
IT'S C. QUICK IS THE CAUSE OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS OR SEEK WHAT
IS NOT A CAUSE OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND THE ANSWER IS IT'S
NOT A BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
IT IS A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR --
AND THOSE OF YOU THAT COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT KNOW THAT WHEN
YOU SAT ON WHEN YOU SAT ON CITY
COUNCILS AND BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS AND YOU SEE THE
NUMBER OF PROJECTS IN THE NUMBER
OF HOUSING PROJECTS THAT COME
BEFORE YOU -- IN SEQUELLITIGATION -- YOU KNOW WE ALSO
CAN PLAY I HAVE A STUDY THAT
SAYS ACTS AND I HAVE A STUDY
THAT SAYS WHY AND THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT SO FRUITFUL FOR
DISCUSSION.
I'M THE THING THAT I IN THE
ANALYSIS PARTICULARLY THAT I
WANTED TO COMMENT ON WAS.
THIS IDEA THAT WE'VE DONE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SEQUEL
STREAMLINING N THE BUILDING AND
WHY ISN'T THAT ENOUGH -- SEQUEL
ACTUALLY BEFORE WE DID THE WHOLE
HOST OF ADDITIONAL -- EXEMPTIONS
AND STREAMLINING CAME WITHOUT
SOME VERY THOUGHTFUL
STREAMLINING WHEN IT WAS FIRST
ENACTED AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT --
CREATIVE ATTORNEYS HAVE FOUND
WAYS AROUND IT I I SORT OF
ANALOGIZE IT TO THE TAX CODE IS
THAT PEOPLE DO THEIR BEST TO PUT
IT TOGETHER AND THEN PEOPLE ARE
CREATIVE AND THEN WE HAVE TO
KEEP.
SORT OF COMING BACK AND
LEGISLATING AROUND LOOPHOLES AND
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF THAT --
THE MITIGATED NEGATIVE
DECORATION DECLARATION WHICH IS
PROBABLY THAT SORT OF PARAMOUNT
SEAQUEST REMINDING ISSUE.
IS A TERRIFIC IDEA BECAUSE IT
RECOGNIZES THAT.
IT'S REALLY DIFFERENT IF YOU'RE
DOING AN INFILL HOUSING IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT AN INFILL
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT OR YOU'RE
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW A LARGE
INDUSTRIAL REFINERY OR OTHER
PROJECT IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW OUGHT TO REFLECT.
THE MAGNITUDE DIFFERENCE IN
THOSE PROJECTS AND THE PROBLEM
IS THAT FOR MANY HOUSING
PROJECTS.
WHO MIGHT WANT TO GO FORWARD
WITH A MEDICATED NEGATIVE
DECLARATION THERE?
IN A SITE THAT'S KNOWN FOR
HOUSING MORE CONTEMPLATED IN A
PLAN.
IF THERE IS LOCAL CONTROVERSY
AROUND THE PROJECT SOMETIMES THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WON'T EVEN LET
YOU PROCEED WITH YOUR MEDICATED
NEGATIVE DECLARATION AND THEY
WILL SAY TO YOU DIRECTLY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE -- ANALYTICAL TOOL
WITHIN SEA QUEST BUT GIVEN THE
CONTROVERSY WE KNOW THERE'S
GONNA BE LITIGATION SO YOU MIGHT
AS WELL DO AN E. I. R. FROM THE
BEGINNING.
AND SO THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE
IN FOR THE OTHER -- STREAMLINING --
THAT'S NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS I
COULD SHARE SIMILAR STORIES --
AND THEN I THINK THE FINAL THING
I'LL SAY IS THAT.
THE REASON.
THAT -- THE APPROACHING THIS
BILL FRANKLY WAS DEVELOPED FOR
THE KINGS ARE WE KNOW WHERE WE
WE ARE FORESEEN IS BECAUSE I
THINK FOLKS RECOGNIZE THAT THE
GOAL IS NOT -- TO GET OUT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
APPROACH THAT LOWERS ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL OBLIGATIONS LOWERS
AND NAME -- MITIGATION
REQUIREMENTS OR IN ANY WAY
CONSTRAINS -- THE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT WHICH IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF SEEK WHAT YOU
DO YOU PREPARE YOUR DOCUMENT YOU
HAVE A PUBLIC MEETINGS ABOUT IT
GOES BEFORE THE COUNCIL AND WHAT
THIS REALLY FOCUSES ON IS SEQUEL
LITIGATION ABUSE.
TRYING TO MAKE THAT PROCESS GO
FASTER AND MAKE CLEAR AND I
THINK THAT THIS IS ESPECIALLY
COMPELLING IN A HOUSE IN CONTEXT.
BUT IF YOU HAVE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT HAS SAID YES WE
WANT THIS HOUSING PROJECT AND WE
WANT THIS HOUSING PROJECT IN
THIS SITE.
IF PEOPLE RAISE ISSUES THAT
ABOUT IT IN LITIGATION IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT IF THE COURT
FINDS THAT.
ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION IS NECESSARY THAT THE
PROJECT SHOULD HAVE TO DO IT BUT
THERE IS NO REASON.
TO HOLD UP THE ENTIRE PROJECT
UNTIL THAT HAPPENS AND SOME WILL
SAY WELL IF YOU START THE
PROJECT AND YOU MIGHT DO DAMAGE
IN THE MEANTIME WHAT THE BILL IS
CRAFTED IN SUCH A WAY TO ENSURE.
THAT -- IF THERE IS -- YOU KNOW
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS IF THERE
ARE ISSUES RELATED TO SACRED
SITES THAT FRANKLY CAN'T GET
UNDONE THOSE ARE THINGS FOR
WHICH INJUNCTIVE RELIEF IS
APPROPRIATE SO.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR T MAKING
THIS CONVERSATION A LITTLE MORE
PUBLIC AND AS FOR YOUR I FELT.
I THINK I AGREE WITH WHAT HE
SAID -- FOLKS WANT TO WEIGH IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING YELLING EVER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE'RE NOT REFLECTED IN
THE ANALYSIS BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I ANYONE WHO WANTS TO BE AN
OPPOSITION RAISE.
OPPOSITION THE BILL.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
WITNESSES ADDRESS ARRANGE WITH
YOURSELF THEN WE'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE THAT ON
SO IF YOU COULD.
CREATE SOME SPACE OF THE DICE
I'M SORRY IT'S SO [inaudible]
BUSY HERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHILE THEY
FIGURE OUT [inaudible]
WITH JOHN.
MORNING JOE REMEMBERS TEN POUND
FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION.
THE COUNCIL'S OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR AND THE OTHER
PENDING BILLS YOU'RE HAVING.
AT THIS MORNING IS LIMITED TO
THE COURT IMPACTS OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND IT'S SIGNIFICANT
INTERFERENCE.
WITH THE COURT'S FUNDAMENTAL
DUTY TO PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN ALL OTHER CASES ON
THE COURT'S DOCKET.
THIS TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAY
ULTRA CALENDAR PREFERENCE HAS
THE PRACTICAL EFFECT.
OF PUSHING ALL OFTHE CASES ON
THE COURT'S DOCKET TO THE BACK
OF THE LINE.
EVEN CASES THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS ALREADY PRIORITIZE JUST FOR
A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THE HOMEOWNER IF AN ACTION WAS
BROUGHT INTO THE HOME OWNER BILL
OF RIGHTS WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
HOUSING OBVIOUSLY THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED A VERY BROAD
PACKAGE COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE TO
TRY TO PROTECT PEOPLE.
FROM THE FORECLOSURE CRISIS IN
IMPROPER FORECLOSURES SEVEN
ACTION UNDER THE HOMEOWNER BILL
OF RIGHTS.
OR AN INSURANCE BAD FAITH OR
OTHER CLAIMS BROUGHT BY
HOMEOWNERS WHO'VE LOST THEIR
HOMES IN THE RECENT DEVASTATING
FIRES IN SANTA ROA.
OR THE MUD SLIDES IN SANTA
BARBARA THOSE CASES MOVED TO THE
BACK OF THE LINE.
OTHER HOUSING RELATED CASES FOR
EXAMPLE HOUSING DISCRIMINATION
OR AN EIGHTY A LAWSUIT BROUGHT
BY PEOPLE WITH MENTAL OR OTHER
DISABILITIES.
IN FACT THERE WAS A RECENT
ARTICLE IN THE LA TIMES WHERE
THIS US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
FOUND ONGOING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST A AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES SO THAT
LITIGATION WOULD MOVE TO THE
BACK OF THE LINE.
JUST A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES AND
NON HOUSING RELATED AREAS WOULD
ALSO BE ADVERSELY AFFECTED FOR
EXAMPLE.
A PERSONAL INJURY ACTION
INVOLVING A SEVERELY BRAIN
DAMAGED CHILD.
ELDER ABUSE LITIGATION INVOLVING
DYING PLAINTIFFS CIVIL ACTIONS
INVOLVING HUMAN TRAFFICKING WAGE
THEFT.
THE I COULD GIVE MANY MANY
EXAMPLES THESE AND OTHER
IMPORTANT CASES ON THE COURT'S
DOCKET THIS WILL ALL TAKE LONGER
TO DECIDE WITH THIS SUPER
XCELERATED CALENDAR PREFERENCE.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE -- THIS XCELERATED COUNT
CALENDAR PREFERENCE OF SECRET
CUSE OF ACTION WILL NOT PROVIDE.
THE SECURITY THAT THE PROPONENTS
ARE SEEKING.
THE JUSTIFICATION THAT WE'VE
ALWAYS HEARD ABOUT THE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY TIMELINE IS
THE CERTAINTY THAT SUPPOSEDLY
WOULD COME.
WITH THE LITIGATION BEING
COMPLETELY WRAPPED UP.
IN A IN THIS RELATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT OUR EXPERIENCE IN ACTUAL A.
B. NINE HUNDRED STREAMLINING
CASES IS THE EXACT OPPOSITE
THEIR LITIGATION AGAINST THE
WARRIORS ARENA.
AND THE LITIGATION AGAINST THE
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SUNSET
BOULEVARD PROJECT BOTH HAD
MULTIPLE LAWSUITS MULTIPLE
CAUSES OF ACTION WHERE THE
SEQUEL PORTION.
WAS ON THE SUPER ACCELERATED
TIMELINE BUT THE REGULAR -- NON
SEQUEL PORTIONS OF THE
LITIGATION PROCEEDED UNDER THE
USUAL CIVIL PROCEDURE TIME LINES
NOT PROVIDING THE CERTAINTY THAT.
IS SUPPOSEDLY THE CORNERSTONE
FOR THIS APPROACH.
THE COUNCIL ALSO IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL IN THE SIMILAR BILLS YOU'LL
BE CARRYING THAT SEVERELY LIMIT.
THE COURT'S ABILITY TO ISSUE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
THE JUDGES TO HEAR THESE CASES
WILL TELL YOU THAT IT IS VERY
COMMON NOT FOR THE ENTIRE --
SEQUEL PROCESS THE BIT TO HAVE
BEEN DONE IMPROPERLY BUT THAT
THERE MAY BE ONE OR TWO ITEMS.
THAT ARE IN NEED OF FIXING AND
THAT ARE TARGETED IN JUNCTION IS
ISSUED TO TAKE CARE OF JUST
THOSE SO WHAT THESE LIMITS ON
INJECTED RELIEF TO THE STATE.
JUDGE REGARDLESS OF THE FACTS.
AND REGARDLESS OF THE LAW THAT
YOU WOULD NORMALLY APPLY IN
THESE CASES YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
PROHIBITED FROM ISSUING THAT
TARGETED IN JUNCTION INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF.
YOU CAN ONLY ENFORCE AN
INJUNCTION OR ISSUE AN
INJUNCTION IN CASES WHERE -- THE
IMMINENT THREAT OF PUBLIC CALMER
INTERFERENCE WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN ARTIFACTS WHICH IS
CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO COME UP --
IN IN MANY CASES IN PRACTICE.
SO THOSE THOSE -- CONSTRAINTS --
INTERFERE WITH THE COURT'S
INHERENT AUTHORITY TO FASHION
APPROPRIATE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
AND IT RAISES A SERIOUS
SEPARATION OF POWERS -- QUESTION
FINALLY WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE EXTREMELY BROAD SCOPE
OF THIS IN THE OTHER BILLS
YOU'RE HEARING TODAY. TO DATE.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE SUPER
XCELERATED TIMELINES HAVE ONLY
APPLIED TO A TOTAL.
OF FIFTEEN PROJECTS TEN THAT
HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED UNDER A B..
NINE HUNDRED ANGLE WITH AN ACE
PROJECTS THAT WERE ENACTED LAST
YEAR.
AND THE CAPITOL BUILDING IN ACTS
AND RELATED STATE OFFICE
BUILDING PROJECTS -- OR TO DATE --
THE ONLY PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS SUPER
STREAMLINING APPROACH -- THE
DEFINITION OF WHICH PROJECTS ARE
ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS
BILL IS INCREDIBLY BROAD AND SO
THE ADVERSE IMPACTS ON LITIGANTS
ON OUR DOCKET -- EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN ALL OF OUR COURTS WOULD
REALLY BE MUCH MORE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED.
IF YOU WERE TO APPLY THIS SUPER
XCELERATED SCHEME TO THIS VERY
LARGE CATEGORY PROJECT THE FINAL
THING I'D MENTION THIS.
AND THEN MY GOOD FRIEND MS
GILSON OF REFERENCE THE ANALYSIS
THE MIDDLE SISTER IS A VERY GOOD
JOB OF POINTING OUT WHAT THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE EMPIRICAL
EVIDENCE IS WITH RESPECT TO SEEK
WITH.
THINK WHAT ISSUES ARE OUTSIDE
OUR PURVIEW BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE AS THE ANALYSIS FOUND
OUT THAT IT DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
THE WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE
CURRENTLY SUPPORTS.
OF THE UNDERLYING PREMISE OF
THIS PARTICULAR -- KIND OF
LEGISLATION AND IN LIGHT OF THAT
INFORMATION AND ALL OF THE
REASONS THAT I JUST -- RECOUNTED
THE COUNCIL MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
NUMBER THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
YES SIR -- YES BRENNAN DAWSON
WAS HERE COULD CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THEIR HARD
WORK ON THE BILLS TODAY AND
PUTTING UP MY BADGERING ON MY
CONCERNS FOR THE BILL -- FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY OUR FRIENDS
OUR JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE ALSO
OPPOSE SB TO EIGHTY FOUR A WE
AGREE THE SP THREE EIGHTY FOUR
WOULD BE BAD FOR THE COURTS BUT
WE GO FURTHER IN OPPOSITION AND
HOLD THAT.
WOULD ACTUALLY BE BAD FOR SEQUEL
IN GENERAL -- OUR FIRST CONCERN
IS THE BROAD NATURE WHICH MR
PONE RT SPOKE -- TO SECOND WE
WOULD NOTE THAT -- SP THREE
EIGHTY FOUR IS NO A. B..
NINE HUNDRED SB THIRTY FOUR LIKE
MANY OF THE BILLS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD OF THAT WILL COME BEFORE
YOU TODAY -- IS MODELED AFTER
CERTAIN REVISIONS IN EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED RICH AWARDED CERTAIN
PROJECTS THAT MET RIGOROUS
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS WITH
EXPEDITED YOU JUDICIAL REVIEW.
OF SIERRA CLUB OPPOSE AB NINE
HUNDRED BECAUSE IT IS OUR BELIEF
THAT THAT'S ABOUT POLICY
GENERALLY HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE
TO NOTE THAT EVEN THAT BILL
PROVIDED CERTAIN ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS.
AND THAT ESPY TWO EIGHTY FOUR
DOES NOTHING OF THE SORT.
THE BILL ONLY REQUIRES --
CERTAIN -- ASPECTS WITH REGARD
TO HOUSING UNITS BUT DOES
NOTHING TO REQUIRE CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF THE GARDEN BARMAN
PROTECTION -- AND SECOND SP
THREE EIGHTY FOUR WE WOULD ARGUE
FOR SAKES ENVIRONMENTAL AND FOR
THIS SEQUENCE FORCING MECHANISMS --
SP THREE TO FOUR DOES NOT
PROVIDE I MEAN DOES NOT PROVIDE
IT SEQUEL EXEMPTION PER SE AN
ASSET SEQUEL SEQUEL WOULD.
PROPONENTS WOULD HAVE TO UNDERGO
SEQUEL PROCESS THESE HOWEVER IT
DOES APPLY TO THE JUDICIAL
REVIEW PORTION OF THE SECRET
PROCESS WHICH IS.
THE ONLY ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
THAT SECRET PROVIDES -- ALTHOUGH
SECRET FOR REVIEW -- WELL THE
SEEKER V. PROVIDE COMMUNITIES
WITH RECORD A REQUISITE
OPPORTUNITIES PARTICIPATING
PUBLIC PROCESS HE'S MITIGATE
TOMORROW DISTRESS AND
DEGRADATION MANY COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
RELY ON SEQUEL LITIGATION AS ITS
ONLY MEANS OF FOR SALON INSURE
THAT THE AIR THEY BREATHE IN THE
WATER THEY DRINK IS CLEAN.
AT THREE THIRTY FOURS
INTERFERENCE WITH THE JUDICIAL
PROCESSES WILL HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL IN AFFECT FOR THESE
PLAINTIFFS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO LIMITING INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
LITIGATION BROUGHT PURSUANT TO
SEEK WORK IN MATERIALLY AFFECT
HOW LEAD AGENCY CONCLUDES THAT
THE PROJECT IS ENVIRONMENTALLY
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE.
AND AS SUCH A PROJECT AND CHANGE
YOU TO LITIGATION BASED ON C.
QUOTE -- BECAUSE THE PROJECT AND
CHANGE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF IS
OFTEN GRANTED BY A COURT TO
PRESERVE THE STATUS QUO UNTIL
DETERMINATION OF THE MERITS OF
THE SECRET JOHNSTON UP CAN BE
MADE.
SINGER ENJOYING CONSTRUCTION OF
A PROJECT IS OFTEN NECESSARY TO
PREVENT FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION AS WELL CONTAINING
ANY ONGOING DEGRADATION --
ENCLOSING MANY DEVELOPERS AND
MANY LEGISLATORS INCLUDING THE
AUTHOR HAS STATED A VARIATION OF
THE FOLLOWING.
IF WE CAN GIVE EXPEDITED JUST
REVIEW TO STADIUMS WE CAN GIVE
IT TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT ALTHOUGH I
COMMEND THESE ALL THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE THE STATEMENT FOR THEIR
ONE EIGHT FOR THE DESIRE TO BE
CONSISTENT.
OF THE POLICY OF TRADING A
BENEFIT TO DEVELOPERS FOR AN
UPPER PLAINS OPPORTUNITY FULLY
HEARD AND RECEIVE THEIR
PREFERRED OUTCOME -- IS NOT IS
NOT A POLICY THAT WE WOULD HAVE --
TO PROMOTE -- IT WAS A BAD
POLICY IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
WHEN IT WAS DESIGNED AND IT'S
ABOUT POLICY TODAY.
SO I UNDERSTAND A NONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HERE
TODAY ACTUALLY VOTED ON THAT
POLICY HOWEVER YOU DO HAVE THE
CHANCE. TO REJECT THE NOTION OF
EXTENDING THAT POLICY TO OTHER
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL -- AND
LASTLY WE JUST ALSO NOTE THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS WHEN IT
COMES EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
REGARDING SEQUELS EFFECT ON THAT
OCCASION AND HOW.
HOW OLD LITTLE AS SICK
REALIZATION IS ACTUALLY OCCURRED
IN THE STATE OF PER THE -- AG'S
OFFICE ITSELF HAS SAID THAT
THERE IS LESS THAN TWENTY CASES
PER YEAR WHEN IT COMES TO
SIMPLIFICATION.
AND EVEN OF THOSE CASES -- LESS
THAN 1% OF THOSE ACTUALLY FIND.
THAT SEQUEL LITIGATION IS THAT
PROBLEM FOR DEVELOPMENT AND SO
WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
SB THREE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR I HAVE
OTHER FOLKS WHEN I'M WAS
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CHELSEA TO
I'M A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
CENTER ON RACE POVERTY AND
ENVIRONMENT.
WE ALSO OPPOSE SP -- THREE
EIGHTY FOUR EXPEDITING LEGAL
ACTIONS LAMENTING JUDICIAL
REMEDIES WILL NOT ONLY HURT
VARMINT BUT WILL HURT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
AS EUROPEAN ARMOR MO JUSTICE
ALLIES OFTEN RELY ON THE COURTS
TO PROTECT COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.
IN WHICH THE COMMUNITY HEALTH IS
DEPENDENT UPON.
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR WHERE
[inaudible]
THE OPPOSITION.
THAILAND IS THE NUMBER MICHAEL'S
WORKING OR NOT. TO BE CLEAR BUT
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA WE WANT
TO MAKE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
SICK WAS NOT THE PROBLEM TO
HOUSING PRODUCTION -- I'M SURE
MANY PEOPLE HERE HAVE READ THE
STUDY -- BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROFESSIONALS OF
SURVEY OF COUNTIES AND CITIES
SHOWING THAT HOUSE IN HOUSING
CRISIS PERSISTS.
DUE TO THE PRIMARY FACTORS OF
HIGH BUILDING COSTS NON SEQUEL
RELATED NEIGHBORHOOD OPPOSITION
LACK OF AVAILABLE SITES.
IN PARTICULAR FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION ONE OF THE
MAIN BARRIERS IS ALSO LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCING.
SO RESPECTIVELY RESPECTFULLY
ARCHER NOVA ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THE TEACHER MEMBERS NIKITA CRIED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL WERE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS BUT WE
ARE POSTED ONLINE -- COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE SIERRA CLUB
THANK YOU CAN.
BRIAN A WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW BAKER
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE.
ERIN RYE BREAD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
ALSO DIDN'T MAKE THE ANALYSIS
BUT WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OKAY ARE SO THE ITEMS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION -- ANY.
QUESTIONS REMEMBERS MISS
MINIMIZED HER.
MY QUESTION IS OF RIDGES
JUDICIAL COUNCIL -- SINCE THERE
IS A A QUESTION.
ON ALL OF THESE ARE ATTEMPTS
HERE.
TO SPEED UP ALL THE SEA GLOW
REVIEW OUR WITHOUT HIM HIM
PAIRING I THINK THE ACTUAL
REVIEW OF THE E. I. R. AND THE
PROTECTIONS THAT PROVIDES.
TO THE ENVIRONMENT OUR HOUSE ARE
MANY CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A SEQUEL COURT IF YOU
WILL OR SOMETHING THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE.
A TWO THREE OTHER BILLS HERE
WITH THE SAME IDEA.
AND WE HAVE A GOVERNOR ON VERY
VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES IN.
SO IF WE HAVE A CRISIS IN QUOTES.
AND WE HAVE EMERGENCY IT WOULD
BE MY THOUGHT THAT MAYBE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL COULD CONSIDER
THE WAY TO CREATE.
OUR PROCESS IN A COURT IF YOU
WILL THAT COULD REALLY DEAL WITH
THESE SO THAT BOTH SIDES OF
EVERY ARGUMENT HAVE.
REALLY A VERY THOROUGH HEARING
AND LO AND BEHOLD WE MIGHT FIND
A RESOLUTION THE SEQUEL DOES THE
JOB IS SUPPOSED TO DO BUT IN IT
IS NOT ALWAYS BECOME THE BAD GUY
THE BLACK CAT.
IN CREATING ALL THESE PROBLEMS
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I SERVED
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT BOTH
CAROLINIAN ON CITY COUNCIL.
AND WE FOUND YOU KNOW ARGUMENTS
ON BOTH SIDES OF MANY OF THE
DEVELOPERS TO BE VERY RELEVANT
IN IN TRYING TO FIND THAT
BALANCE SO YOU CAN SERVE BOTH
SIDES OF THIS.
RIGHT I THINK IS THE JUDICIAL
OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
SO I JUST ASK AND KIND OF THROW
THAT OUT FOR CONSIDERATION
OBVIOUSLY NOT TODAY.
THAT -- THAT YOU TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE YOU'RE
GONNA MAY BE MAKING THE SAME
COMMENTS ON EVERY BILL THAT'S
COMING BEFORE US.
THESE AUTHORS OF WORK VERY HARD
TO TRY TO NAVIGATE THROUGH AND
INSURE THAT HE COULD DOES THE
JOB THAT WAS INTENDED TO DO WHEN
IT WAS PUT INTO PLACE MANY YEARS
AGO.
AND JUST BRIEFLY APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS -- THERE HAS BEEN --
PROPOSALS TO CREATE SPECIALITY
SECRET -- THAT SENATOR CORBETT
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER DICKINSON.
TRIED IN AROUND TWENTY TWELVE OR
SO WE DID OPPOSE THIS WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF OPPOSING
SPECIALLY COURT LEGISLATION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN EFFICIENT
WAY OF ADMINISTERING.
OUR COURTS THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
SEQUEL CASES -- YOU KNOW WE
DON'T CONTROL WHAT CASES GET
FILED IN WHICH COURTS AND HOW
OFTEN -- ARE.
OUR COURTS ARE NOT TELLING US
THEY NEED MORE SICK BUT JUDGES
ARE SPECIALTY COURTS TO HANDLE
THE CASES.
THE BIGGEST AREA OF DELAY IN
SEQUEL ACCORDING TO MY EXPERTS
IS FIGHTS OVER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD AND THERE
ARE SOME IDEAS THAT WE HAVE THAT
WE'VE OFFERED TO TO MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO STREAMLINE
THAT PROCESS -- BUT THINK
RECORDS ARE SPECIALLY COURTS ARE
SPECIAL FUNDING FOR SICK WITH
JUDGES IS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE THINK IS THE BEST WAY OF
PROCEEDING IN HANDLING THESE
ISSUES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE.
OKAY ARE IN MY I HEAR THIS A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE
DISCUSSION THAT HAS -- THAT
WE'VE SEEN SO FAR -- THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT -- THE SPORTS
STADIA THAT HAVE [inaudible]
GOTTEN.
EXPEDITED REVIEW -- DID RECEIVE
EXPERT REVIEW BUT I I GUESS THE
THE THE THING IS THAT IN ALL
THOSE CASES INCLUDING THE NINE
HUNDRED CASES -- THERE ARE THERE
ARE THERE WERE TERMS THAT WERE
INCLUDED THAT MADE THE PROJECTS
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUPERIOR THE
IDEA BEING THAT IF WE'RE GOING --
TO GRANT LENIENCY UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FROM A QUALITY ACT.
ARE WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE A A
NEXT LEVEL OF ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROJECT AND I WILL SAY THAT'S AT
LEAST.
ARE A LARGE PART OF THE SPIRIT
BEHIND THE PROPOSED DEMANDS.
ON THE OTHER BILLS.
I THAT ARE GONNA BE HEARD THIS
MORNING.
I AND I YOU KNOW AND I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE THE YOU KNOW
THE LOGIC OF THE AUTHOR -- BUT
YOU KNOW THERE THERE DIDN'T SEEM
TO BE.
I'M GOOD FRIENDS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A LOT OF
INTEREST IN IN IN.
YOU'RE TAKING AMENDMENTS TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL I THINK THE
OTHERS TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW GET THIS GET HIS
IDEAS OUT THERE AND I I RESPECT
THAT -- BUT IT DOES MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I WILL SAY
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF A
RELEVANT APPLICABLE EXEMPTIONS
ALREADY EXIST AND AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE OUTLINED ON PAGES FIVE
AND SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
INFILL PROJECTS CONSISTENT
GENERAL PLAN CONSISTS OF A
SPECIFIC PLAN MIXED USE PROJECTS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- THERE'S
TRANSIT ORIENTED SO THERE ARE A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ALREADY EXIST THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE DISCUSSED AT THE HEARING
THAT WE HAD -- WITH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON ON SEA
QUEST.
I AM I WILL SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THE THE THE PRIMARY CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION -- WHAT WE KNOW WITH
WITH EXCEPTION OF A FEW THAT
WERE RAISED -- WELL WITH
PARTICULAR THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS
CONCERNS I THINK WE'RE PRIMARILY
CONCERNS THAT RELATE -- TO THE
PURVIEW OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND IF THIS BILL AND
OTHER BILLS I GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE ALL OF THEM WILL GO
OVER JUST A COMMITTEE WHERE.
I THINK THEY'RE GONNA.
QUITE FRANKLY MEET A GREAT DEAL
OF SKEPTICISM -- BECAUSE OF THE
IMPLICATIONS TO OUR JUDICIARY
AND THE IMPACT ON ON YOU KNOW ON
ON THE ALL ALL THE VARIOUS KIND
OF SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED BY -- THE THE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I'M SO THAT'S A
SEPARATE SET OF ISSUES I I THINK
OUR OUR ATTITUDE HERE HAS BEEN --
REALLY ABOUT IT -- YOU MOVED
SAYING THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE SOME LENIENCY ON SEE WHAT
WE REALLY NEED TO SEE NEXT LEVEL
ENVIRONMENTALLY QUALITY I'M
FINALLY SUPERIOR PROJECTS.
AND DONE.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
[inaudible]
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
THIS BILL TODAY BUT I I
CERTAINLY THINK TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THIS
ISSUE SENATOR -- YOU YOU WILL
TAKE INTEREST IN THE OTHER BILLS
THAT WILL BE HEARD THIS MORNING
WHERE THE AUTHORS DID WORK VERY
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE STAFF.
AND THE COMMITTEE ON ON TAKING
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD -- THAT
WOULD MEET THOSE GOALS AND AND I
KIND OF INVITE YOU TO ENGAGE
WITH THOSE OFFICES AND TALK TO
THEM.
AND IF IF THIS BILL DOESN'T GET
OUT TODAY -- SO.
WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
I HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CAST A VOTE
BUT BUT MINIMIZED HERE YEAH YEAH
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
IN ALL THE AUTHORS THAT.
LOOKING OUT THIS VERY VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM WE HAVE THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I FOUND TO BE.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING I WOULD
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE WAY IT
FOCUSES IN ON FIFTY OR MORE OUR
HOUSING UNITS SO.
FAR WITHOUT A MOVE THAT TO YOU
KNOW AND HOLDS OUT GOING FORWARD --
WE CAN HAVE ON CONTINUED
DISCUSSION BECAUSE WOULD BE MY
HOPE THIS YEAR WE GET SOMEWHERE
ON THE PRODUCTION OF HOUSING YOU
KNOW AND THESE ARE ALL GREAT
STARS AND I NEED TO SEE HIM JUST
GO AWAY.
SO WITHOUT I'LL MOVE.
APPRECIATE THAT MINIMIZE YOUR
WILL WILL WILL I TAKE UP THE
BILL FOR A VOTE WHEN -- AND WHEN
WHEN THE COMMITTEE HAS A QUORUM
BUT THANK YOU AND AND STICK
AROUND BECAUSE OF THE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION.
IF YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WHAT YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SENATOR -- A COUPLE THINGS THAT
WAS MENTIONED -- BY THE THOSE IN
OPPOSITION -- IS THERE'S BEEN
MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR SEQUEL
REFORM BUT NONE OF THEM'S WORK
AT SECOND WHILE THE REASON I
DIDN'T TAKE THE MEASUREMENTS AS
IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF THESE
BILLS THAT COME FORWARD ARE VERY
GOOD THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
MAHER EXPLAINS WHY IN A MINUTE.
BUT WHEN YOU TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS OF WATERS IT DOWN AND
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN THAT'S WHY
WERE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
HOUSING UNITS SHORT.
AGAIN ONE OF THE LARGEST
DEMOGRAPHIC SLEEVE IN OUR STATE
ARE HIGHLY EDUCATED YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO BUY HOMES HERE.
IN WAS INTERESTING SOME OF WHAT
THE OPPOSITION SAID -- I I LOVE
IT HERE IT IS THE GENTLEMAN
RIGHT HERE SAID IT IT'S BAD FOR
THE COURTS.
WE'LL SEE I'M GOT ELECTED TO
REPRESENT MY CONSTITUENTS SO I
GIVE MORE PRIORITY TO THE
CITIZENS OF OUR STATE FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS.
PEOPLE NEED HOUSING MORE THAN I
AM -- THE COURT SYSTEM OR THE
BUREAUCRACY AND AND AND ANOTHER
COMMENT WAS MADE THAT THAT
SOMEHOW I THINK THIS BILL
PREFERS -- DEVELOPERS YOU KNOW
OVER YOU KNOW SICK WHAT.
THAT THAT'S NOT ACCURATE EITHER
I PREFER OUR CITIZENS TO GET IN
HOMES BECAUSE AS OUR GOVERNOR
SAYS IS THAT -- C. A. R. SALES
OF THE BILLING INDUSTRY SAYS WE
DO HAVE A HOUSING SHORTAGE
WRITING -- SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR YOUR MEDIUM -- PRICE HOME IN
CALIFORNIA SO AGAIN IT'S NOT
THAT I PREFER DEVELOPERS I
PREFER OUR CITIZENS TO BE ABLE
TO GET IN HOMES I WANT TO KEEP
THEM HERE KEEP THEM PRODUCTIVE.
AND I THINK HOME OWNERSHIP IS A
DREAM FOR PEOPLE AND THEN
ANOTHER THING WHICH I THOUGHT
WAS WAS IN SOME WAYS YOU SHOW
HOW.
SOME PEOPLE GET -- MIRED DOWN IN
THE BUREAUCRACY IS -- THAT ONE
OF THE GERMS BEGIN APPEAR TALKED
ABOUT THIS HE MENTION OF MAYBE
THREE OR FOUR TIMES A SUPER
ACCELERATED TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
A PROCESS.
THAT IS HORRIBLE I MEAN THAT IS
SO SLOW WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
STATES AROUND US WHETHER IT'S
UTAH IDAHO.
TEXAS OR ARIZONA TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DAYS I MEAN THESE TRACKS
ARE BUILT GONE AND ARE SOLD OUT
BY THEM SO EVEN OUT PROCESS IT'S
NOT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT
IT'S NOT SUPER ACCELERATED AT
ALL IT'S JUST A MATTER BEING
MIRED DOWN IN BUREAUCRACY.
AND AND AS MY CLOSING STATEMENT
THIS GET THIS BILL IS GOOD FOR
CITIZENS IT'S GOOD FOR OUR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS IT'S GOOD TO
MOVE PEOPLE UP BECAUSE WE WANT
TO HELP ALL BOATS THE FLOAT WE
WANNA -- WHEN WHEN YOU GET THE
MIDDLE CLASS UPPER MIDDLE CLASS
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS YOU WANT TO
GET THE LOWER CLASS?
RAISE THEM UP TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND POOR PEOPLE TO GET OUT
OF YOU KNOW -- SHELTERS AND THAT
KIND OF THING AND ACTUALLY GET
HIM IN THE HOMES AND THAT'S WHY
WHAT THIS DOES IS THIS HELPS --
CONSTRUCTION FOR CALIFORNIA BE
COMPETITIVE IN THE HOME BUYING
MARK INSTEAD OF BEING THE THIRD
WORST STATE.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO MOVE UP THAT
LADDER SO THAT'S THAT'S MY STORY
AND I'M STICKING TO IT NINE
RESHAPE MY MY FOLKS HERE TODAY A
PRE APPRECIATE THOUGH I MEAN I
WILL SAY YOUR OWN WITNESS DID
SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW.
EVEN IF HE WAS NOT THAT.
IS NOT THE CAUSE OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE CERTAINLY HAD A
WHOLE HEARING ABOUT THIS -- BUT
THERE ARE THERE ARE SOME THERE
ARE SOME CASES OUT THERE WHERE
IT'S PROVED TO BE A CHALLENGE --
I DO I WILL SAVE MAYBE MAYBE
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNE FOR BOTH OF
US TO JOIN HANDS AND IN ASKING --
FOR IT NO MAJOR ENHANCEMENTS OF
FUNDING FOR THE COURTS.
SO THAT THEY REALLY CAN -- YOU
KNOW BE ABLE TO DO THEIR JOBS
AND AND AND TO THE TUNE OF SEVEN
DAYS.
YEAH IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE SUCH A
THE REASON WE KNOCK THAT TONY
SEVENTY DOWN YOU KNOW.
BECAUSE IT IS YES SIR MY WITNESS
MAKE A SMALL POINT ON AT HOME SO
IT IS NOT GONNA DO GET ORGAN
BRANCH.
YOU KNOW IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT.
CAME UP TO IN THE STUDY THAT I
ONCE TALKED ABOUT.
IN THAT SURVEY LOT OF THE
RESPONDENTS SPECIFICALLY ASKED
FOR LITIGATION OR LEAVE YOU KNOW
STREAMLINING THINGS LIKE THAT SO.
EVEN THOUGH THAT SURVEY YOU KNOW
DIDN'T SEEM TO THINK THAT
SIMPLIFICATION ITSELF.
WAS THAT HUGE OF AN IMPEDIMENT
I'M NOT GONNA YOU KNOW DIRECTLY.
GO AGAINST THAT.
THE RSPONSE TO THAT SURVEY YOU
KNOW CITY PLANNING STAFF DID
THINK THAT MORE STREAMLINING
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO THE ISSUE OF
GETTING.
MORE HOUSING PROJECTS MOVING
FORWARD IN THE THER THING THAT
ACTION NOW I REMEMBER.
TO IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA OF
THE EP'S SURVEY AND ALSO THE UC
BERKELEY UC BERKELEY -- PAPERS
AS WELL.
BUT THEY SHOWED IS THAT IT'S
VERY HARD FOR LARGER PROJECTS
LARGER HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
REQUIRE FULL E. R. E. I. R.. TO
GO FORWARD AND IT'S REALLY ONLY
THE SMALLER SIZE PROJECTS OF YOU
KNOW SIXTY TO A HUNDRED UNITS OR
SO.
THAT ARE GETTING OUT THERE GOING
THROUGH THE EXISTING.
EXEMPTIONS AND SO FORTH BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT DATA IT DOES
SHOW THAT -- GETTING THOSE
LARGER PROJECTS APPROVED IS
[inaudible]
DIFFICULT.
YEAH I I I GET IT I I'M IN NJ
THE YOU KNOW I WILL SAY THE
RESPONSES OF IT WE SAID HEY DID
NOT SEE SEE QUIT.
AS AN IMPEDIMENT BUT I BUT I
WILL SAY THAT DID YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA SEE A WILLINGNESS --
TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE OF
EXPEDITING IN THE NEXT COUPLE
BILLS AND AND IF YOU ARE WILLING
TO IMPOSE AT LEAST SOME DEGREE
OF ENVIRONMENT MEDICATION
MEASURES.
HI YOU KNOW I THINK THERE WOULD
BE MORE OPENNESS ON THE PART OF
THE COMMITTEE TO WORK WITH YOU --
BUT THE IDEA THAT WERE LITERALLY
GOING TO AND YOU KNOW TO TO TO
MAKE THIS ENORMOUS CHANGE. TO TO
THE WAY THE SEQUEL WORKS WITHOUT
ANY KIND OF DISCERNIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
I THINK WAS REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
THE VINYL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
TO THE STOMACH BUT THAT BEING
SAID I I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE IN THE NEXT FEW BILLS WHICH
I WELCOME YOU TO GET ENGAGED
WITH -- A WILLINGNESS ON THE
PART OF THIS COMMITTEE TO TO
DEMONSTRATE SOME FLEXIBILITY AS
LONG AS THERE'S A DISCERNIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION ONLINE
AND AND IN IN IN GOOD QUALITY
PROJECTS THAT WE CAN BE PROUD OF
SO.
YET PRESERVE THAT SENATOR AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE FOLKS WHO
CAME IN TO TESTIFY.
AND WILL WILL TAKE UP THE VOTE
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU.
YEAH I KNOW.
I DON'T I JUST TO REMIND THE
VICE CHAIR WE CAN'T TAKE THE
MOTION UNTIL WE HAVE THE CHORDS
OF BOOK BUT ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM YOU CAN MAKE THE MOTION
AND WE'LL TAKE IT UP FOR A VOTE.
OKAY SO -- ARE WE GONNA AT
WHAT'S THAT HE HAS WORKED OUT OF
A SCHEDULE BECAUSE THE ORDER OR
WE'RE GONNA LET CENTER NUMBER GO
FIRST OKAY HI CENTER BRICK SENSE
INTERPRETERS HERE TO PRESENT --
THE REST.
S. BEFORE FIFTY THIS IS -- ITEM
NUMBER THREE IN YOUR AGENDA.
AGENDAS MEMBERS THIS IS A THIS
IS THE ABSOLUTE MOST MODEST OF
THE FOR SICKLE BILLS WE HAVE
TODAY -- BUT IT BUT AN IMPORTANT
BILL AND AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTING -- AS BEFORE DEMI
PERCY WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
UNDER BATES -- YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU SP -- FOUR FIFTY THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH WHICH HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS -- IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT TAKES
MOTELS AND THE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
IN RIGHT NOW AND IT'S SIMPLY?
ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE KITCHENS
INSTALLED SMALL KITCHENS
INSTALLED -- THERE'S PEOPLE
ALREADY LIVING THERE THIS SIMPLY
ALLOWS THE MOTEL OPERATOR. TO
RENOVATE.
IT ASSISTS IN TRANSITIONAL
LIVING -- IT MAKES SENSE AND IT
IS A RELATIVELY MINOR -- THE
SEQUEL MODIFICATION SO WITH ME
HERE IT IS COUNCILMEMBER AL
AUSTIN LONG BEACH CITY COUNCIL
AND DIANA TANG -- MANAGER OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH I CAN JUST BEFORE
WE GO TO YOUR WITNESS IS CAN YOU
GUESS I ACCEPT THE MEMORIES OF
THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER.
WHOA A GOOD MORNING ARCHER ALLEN
AND MEMBERS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO PRESENT AS
BEFORE FIFTY ALONGSIDE SENATOR
UMBERG.
OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH IS A
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
WHICH AS MENTIONED PROPOSE TO
EXAM THE CONVERSION OF MOTEL --
TO TEMPORARY OR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FROM SEA WORLD.
AND CURRENTLY A CONVERSION
TRIGGER SEQUEL BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGE IN USE -- WITHOUT A DOUBT
WE ALL KNOW OF NUISANCE MOTELS
IN EACH OF OUR CITIES AND
DISTRICTS -- IN LONG BEACH WE
RECENTLY MADE EFFORTS TO REDUCE
PUBLIC SAFETY CALLS FOR SERVICE
AT FIFTEEN MOTELS IN OUR CITY --
THE TOP SIX MOTELS FOR CALLS FOR
SERVICE COLLECTIVELY GENERATED
THIRTY ONE HUNDRED CALLS -- FROM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CLEARLY SOMETHING
NEEDS TO CHANGE.
ARE WITHOUT A DOUBT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE HOMELESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS REACHED.
EPIC PROPORTIONS.
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND HALL
HOUSEHOLDS IN MY CITY ARE
PRECARIOUSLY HOUSE.
AND IN AN ESTIMATED FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS EACH YEAR.
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES ALREADY USING TEMPORARY
LIVING AND VARIOUS MOTELS
THROUGHOUT THE CITY.
IN A RECENT -- POINT TIME COUNT
SHOWED EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN
LONG BEACH SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OF INDIVIDUALS REPORTED BEING
SHELTERED.
OVER TWELVE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
REMAIN ON SHELTER.
POVERTY NUISANCE MOTELS INTO
SEPTEMBER AREA WERE SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IS REALLY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT ALWAYS THE
EASY THING TO DO -- IN ADDITION
TO THE PURCHASE OF PROPERTY --
WORKING ALONGSIDE THE COMMUNITY
TINTED IMPROVEMENTS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES INTO
CONVERTING CONVERTING A MOTEL OR
TEMPORARY INTO IN A TEMPORARY
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
THE COST OF SECRET ADS ANYWHERE
FROM A HUNDRED THOUSAND TO A
MILLION DOLLARS TO A PROJECT.
THIS BILL SUPPORTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH ADDRESSING THE
NEED FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
THE NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES
CREATED BY USES MOTELS.
BY EXEMPTING MOTEL CONVERSION
PROJECTS FROM SEQUEL WHILE
ENABLING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAINTAIN.
PERMITTING PROCESSES -- THE CITY
IS A VERY PROUD TO HAVE THE
SUPPORT FROM TWELVE MAYORS
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S MOST
POPULOUS CITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH [inaudible]
YOU.
YOUR AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE ANY OF THE YEAR WITH
THE CITY OF MIAMI YOUR ARMS OKAY
GREAT OUR OTHER FOLKS WANT TO
WIN SUPPORT.
THE STRANGE WE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A GOOD MORNING
TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF -- INJURY
ANTS WE WAS SHOW YOUR AUNT'S WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
PRONTO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
WE'VE DONE A LOT WITH WILL TELL
CONVERSIONS IN ANYTHING THAT
SPEECH PEOPLE AT THE HOUSING.
IS A WELL WORTH A WORTHWHILE
EFFORT.
ALSO ONE EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA FOR
THIS MEASURE AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THIS IS AN
INNOVATIVE AND FOCUSED E. I. R.
OR SEE QUIT EXEMPTION FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THERE PROBABLY
ARE GOING TO BE ANY REAL.
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT THERE WILL BE SOME
COST SAVINGS TIME SAVINGS BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY ALSO LITIGATION
REST SAVINGS SO WE ARE AVOIDING
POTENTIAL LITIGATION CHOKE
POINTS.
WHERE NIMBIS OR OTHERS WILL COME
IN AND TRY TO DELAY THESE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE VITAL
BEYOND THE POINT OF ECONOMIC
VIABILITY SO WE THINK THIS IS?
AN IMPORTANT AND FOCUSED --
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS -- HOUSING
FOR TRANSITIONAL AND SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THANK YOU -- MEMBERS
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SOUTH
AMERICA STAMBERG IN SPORT.
MR KEEFE DONE ABOUT CALIFORNIA
PARMA SOLICITATIONS FROM SPORTS
MEASURE BECAME.
GOOD MORNING TO SEAL IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AS A MAN IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYONE WHO -- ONCE THERE IS
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
THIS NUMBER IS REPETITION
ANALYSIS.
I OKAY SO THE ITEMS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
QUEST DISCUSSION.
YEAH I I MEAN I I THINK THIS IS
A YOU KNOW VERY FOCUSED IN ON I
THINK YOU'VE IDENTIFIED AS AN
AREA WHERE WE CAN YOU KNOW MAKE
A MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE -- FOR
QUALITY OF LIFE IN COMMUNITIES
AND IN A WAY THAT WANT.
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT BACK TILL PROBABLY
IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT -- WRIT
LARGE -- AND SO I I COMMEND YOU
ON ON IDENTIFYING IT AS AN AREA
WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE ON SEQUENCE.
I CERTAINLY GOING TO BE --
RECOMMENDING IT TO PASS --
RECOMMENDATION -- FOR FOR THIS.
BUILDING ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
COMMITTEE AND SO -- IF IF
WITHOUT FURTHER I HAVE QUESTIONS
IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATOR BATES
UP I WANT TO THANK MS TANG AND
COUNCILMEMBER AUSTIN FOR COMING
UP YOUR TEST BY VIRGIN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOOD BRIDGET
YOU COME OUT FROM FROM LONG
BEACH WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
TAKE A VOTE ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- THE DO DO APPRECIATE
THAT THIS STUFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE'RE NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM CENTER WHAT WE HAVE.
WHAT WITH THIS THE DREAM TEAM
HERE WHAT WHAT TELL US WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA DO [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
YEAH -- WHAT'S YOUR PLAN FOLKS
YOU WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST.
OKAY -- SIMULATOR [inaudible]
OKAY.
GREAT SENEGALESE EXONERATIONS
HERE TO PRESENT AS BE SIX TWENTY
ONE THIS ITEM FOR IN YOUR AGENDA
PACKETS MEMBERS.
THESE ARE AT THIS IS A JOINT
AUTHOR BILLS IS THAT'S RIGHT
OKAY -- FIRST DIED AT HERE I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
US.
ON THIS BILL -- SB SIX TWENTY
ONE WILL DO FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- WHAT WE'VE DONE FOR
AS WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
BILLIONAIRES IN THEIR SPORTS
ARENAS AND EVEN OUR OWN
LEGISLATIVE PARKING STRUCTURE?
I RECEIVED -- SEQUESTERING LYING --
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS -- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW DURING THE
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
GOVERNOR NEWSOME.
SAID QUOTE IN RECENT YEARS WITH
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEWS ON
SEQUEL FOR PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
IT'S TIME WE DO THE SAME THING --
FOR HOUSING.
AN SP SIX TWENTY ONE DOES JUST
THAT.
AT THE CALIFORNIA VINYL QUALITY
ACT IS THE HALLMARK OF
CALIFORNIA'S DEDICATION TO
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
OUR STATE'S BROADEST
ENVIRONMENTAL RULE -- THIS BILL
UP HOLDS ALL THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS [inaudible]
AND REVIEWS.
I DOES NOT LIMIT THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO OBJECT TO PROJECTS
UNDER SEQUENCE NOR DOES IT GRANT
ANY NEW EXEMPTION TO SEE WHAT.
THE PROCESS OF PUBLIC INPUT
DEVELOPING AN E. I. R. AND
ABILITY TO CHANGE A PRIVATE
CHALLENGER PROJECT ALL REMAIN
INTACT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ESTABLISHES.
A SET TIME PERIOD IN WHICH THE
COURT OVERSEEING A SECRET
CHALLENGE TO AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT MUST BE
COMPLETED.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT BUILD HOUSING AND IN
RARE EXCEPTIONS.
THAT WE RELY ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO INVEST THEIR OWN
RESOURCES.
THE PROCESS UNDER SB SIX TWENTY
ONE CREATES MORE LEGAL
PREDICTABILITY.
AND CERTAINTY FOR BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE CERTAINLY THIS BUILD VANCE'S
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING GOALS -- IN
THE ANALYSIS -- NUMBER OF ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED -- REGARDING.
HEIGHTENING ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS SHARE YOU RAISE THIS
ISSUE AN EARLIER BILLS THIS
MORNING.
AND WE'RE VERY OPEN TO
INCORPORATING THOSE -- STANDARDS --
IN -- IN PROVIDING FOR THE LET
THE LEGISLATION THAT'S BEFORE
YOUAS YOU KNOW IS SUPPORTED BY
A BROAD COALITION OF HOUSING
ADVOCATES NONPROFITS AND
BUSINESS GROUPS AND I'M JOINED
BY MY JOINT AUTHOR.
SENATOR CABALLERO AND PAT SABLE
HOUSE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
YOU AGREE TO THE MEMBER OF THE
OFFICE.
I MEAN OKAY.
WHEN WE GO THROUGH THOSE TO BE
PRETTY CLEAR -- ON WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
I MEAN I GUESS WE WELL.
AND WE WERE MOVING ON WITH THAT
WE HAVE AGREED THAT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
OFFICE TO DISCUSS POTENTIALLY
ALLOWING SOME EXCUSE AND
PROJECTS -- WE'VE.
WE HAVE AGREED TO A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET INSTEAD OF THREE AND THEN
THEN WE TALKED ABOUT -- THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A FOR THE
HOUSING PROJECTS UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD INVOLVE LEGAL CERTIFIED WE
DID.
I'D SAY WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU TO EXPLORE
SUBSTANTIVE EQUIVALENT. TO THE
LEGAL STANDARD -- BUT YOU KNOW
WHERE WE ARE VERY -- EMPHATIC
ABOUT.
ABOUT NOT.
DEBATING FROM THAT STANDARD IF
WE CAN FIND AN EQUIVALENT -- THE
WE'RE WE'RE OKAY WITH THAT -- WE
TALKED ABOUT IN FILL IN
PROXIMITY TRANSISTOR OP PROJECTS
SITE LESS THAN FIVE ACRES MAX
TWO HUNDRED RESIDENTIAL UNITS.
30% OF WHICH ARE FOR THE HOUSING
FOR MINIMUM THIRTY YEARS.
I THINK THOSE WERE THE YEAH SO
AS YOU'VE EXPLAINED IT.
I CAN SUMMARIZE IT IN MY WORDS
BUT I THINK IT WE ARE IN THE
SAME PAGE THERE.
THE AMENDMENT -- SORRY SORRY. TO
TO INTERRUPT THE FLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- REALLY ONE AT THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
TIME AND ENERGY THAT YOU PUT
INTO LOOKING AT THESE BILLS
BECAUSE I THINK WERE WERE MOVING
IN AND REALLY GOOD DIRECTION AND
I'M I'M REALLY PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY AS CO AUTHOR -- BEST
BE SIX TWENTY ONE WHICH AS YU.
HEARD STREAM LIES IT STREAMLINES
JUDICIAL REVIEW TO INCENTIVIZE
THE OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND THAT --
ALL WE'RE ASKING IS THAT.
THE WHAT WE'VE DONE FOR SPORTS
ARENA MULTIPLE TIMES OVER THE
LAST DECADE IS ALSO APPLIED TO
THE WHAT WE WOULD.
DEEM AT AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ON
THE LACK OF HOUSING HAS FORCED
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS INTO HOMELESSNESS --
AND SO OUR GOAL HERE IS TO
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
BE ABLE -- TO ENERGIZE THE
MARKET HAVE SOME CERTAINTY --
AND BE ABLE TO RESOLVE THE ANY
CONFLICTS THAT MAY OCCUR NOT TO
GET RID OF SEQUIN NOT TO REDUCE
ANY OF ITS PROTECTIONS BUT JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THROUGH --
ALLEGED AT AM MINISTRY TO
PROCESS REVIEWING -- LITIGATION
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PATRICK
SABLE HOUSE I AM -- THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- WHICH
CONSISTS OF THE OF THE LENDERS
AND THE DEVELOPERS OF THE
BUILDERS -- THAT ARE INVOLVED IN --
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS.
FOR SOME THIRTY YEARS NOW AND
WERE -- EXTREMELY PLEASED TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF OF THIS BILL -- WE
THINK THE IT IS GIVEN HOW MUCH
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE -- WITH
REGARD TO THE SIX MILLION DOLLAR.
BOND ISSUE THAT THE IS GOING TO
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT IN THE ADDITIONAL
MONIES THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET -- IN
THAT -- ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IN AND THE ASSEMBLY HAS PROPOSED
THAT THE INCREASE OF SOME FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION.
OF THAT WOULD BE USED -- IN PARK
FOR FOR FOR MIDDLE INCOME AND
AND LOW INCOME HOUSING.
AND IN THE THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AND ADDITIONAL STATE TAX
CREDITS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING AND THEN HIS -- HIS
MOST CHALLENGING -- EFFORT TO TO
PRODUCE -- NOT NOT THE A MILLION
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS IN
THE NEXT -- FIVE YEARS BUT TO TO
TO HE'S PROPOSING.
A THREE MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT -- GIVEN GIVEN ALL
THOSE STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
OF THAT WE NEED TO TAKE THE
EVERY EVERY ACTION THAT WE CAN
TAKE IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE AND
INCENTIVIZE AND KNOCKED.
THE BARRIERS THAT -- THAT STAND
IN THE WAY OF OF OF ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- EVEN THAT
THE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM TODAY AS
YOU WILL RECALL IT ONLY PRODUCES
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND UNITS OF
OF TRULY AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
IN AND WITH THE INCREASED
BUDGETS -- YOU'LL YOU'LL HAVE A
LOT MORE TAX EXEMPT BOND
DEVELOPMENTS GOING FORWARD --
THAT WILL -- MEET THIS -- THIS
CHALLENGE THAT'S THE SET FORTH
HERE TODAY WERE YOU WOULD HAVE A
PROJECT HOPEFULLY OF THE TWO
HUNDRED UNITS -- A HUNDRED TWO
HUNDRED UNITS THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE PRODUCTION OF
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER WHAT WE HAVE
NOW BUT BUT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT --
THAT WE WE FIND EVERY WAY TO
KNOCK DOWN BARRIERS THAT WILL
STOP THAT MONEY OF FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
THE TAX CREDIT COMMITTEE IN THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE FROM GETTING
OUT THE DOOR -- TO HAVE THE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE BUT NOT BE
ABLE TO TO TO CHARGE FORWARD AND
UTILIZE THOSE RESOURCES -- TO TO
DAMPEN THE THE THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE WITH HOMELESSNESS -- IS
IS IS SOMETHING THAT THAT WOULD
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT AND AND
WE NEED TO CHARGE ON SO.
WE WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
WHOLEHEARTEDLY -- AND THANK GOD --
CENTER CUBBY EURO AND AND AND
SENATOR GLAZER UP FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY OUR FOLKS WANT TO WIN
SUPPORT.
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY GOVERNOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT RICHARD.
OR IN SEDONA FROM HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY GREATER SAN FRANCISCO
AND SUPPORT.
CASSIE GILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
HE'S DONE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTIES
AGAIN AND SUPPORT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WE'RE NOT
CHANGING THE SUBSTANTIVE
REQUIREMENTS OF SEQUEL FOR
DISCLOSURE FOR MITIGATION.
SO THIS IS SIMPLY EXPEDITING THE
PROCESS STRUNG WITH SUPPORT THAT --
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THE AMENDMENT AS THE BILL
GOES FORWARD TO MITIGATE COST
IMPACTS THAT MAKE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LESS AFFORDABLE RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAROLING ON HALF OF
THE BURNING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION THEY'RE UNAFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER IN TE
CINNAMON APPLE AREA AND THEY'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS MISSION
LOOK FOR TO SEE THAT BEFORE
THANK YOU.
OKAY OUR FOLKS WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS OUR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
I'M.
OKAY SO.
ARE YOU GONNA DO IS YOUR
ARGUMENT IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
IT WAS.
BEFORE.
OKAY -- MEMBERS TEMPLE FOR THE
USUAL COUNCIL -- ALL THE
COMMENTS I MADE ON THE LAST BILL
WOULD APPLY HERE JUST A COUPLE
OF VERY QUICK POINTS.
I'M THE AUTHOR SAID -- THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT -- IS A
IMPORTANT FEATURE OF THIS BILL
IS THE LEGAL PREDICTABILITY AND
CERTAINTY.
THAT WOULD COME WITH THIS
APPROACH AND AS I INDICATED
BEFORE AND I WANT TO STRESS.
IN THE LITIGATION THAT HAS
HAPPENED TODAY UNDER THE
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS.
THAT CERTAINTY IS NOT THERE
SUBSCRIBE TO IT ANY PROJECT
THAT'S HIGHLY CONTESTED THERE
WILL BE BOTH THE QUIT AND NON
SEQUEL CAUSES OF ACTION AND
LAWSUITS FILED.
IT WILL NOT PROVIDE THE
CERTAINTY THAT THEY ARE SEEKING
WE DO APPRECIATE THE ALL THE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AT THE VERY
END OF THE BILL -- THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TENAX SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE COURTS
FOR HANDLING SEE WHAT CASES BUT
AS I POINTEDOUT.
THAT'S REALLY NOT OUR GOAL AND
WE WE WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE SENTIMENT -- BUT I THINK
GOING OUT IN FUNDING AND PUTTING
CONSTRAINTS ON THE FUNDING FOR
PARTICULAR CATEGORIES OF CASES
IS A REALLY INEFFICIENT WAY OF
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE OVERALL.
ISSUES WE THINK THERE ARE OTHER
STREAMLINING MECHANISMS THAT
COULD BE DONE THAT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON BUT RESPECTFULLY
THIS LIKE WHAT WHAT KIND OF
THINGS.
LIKE WHAT KIND OF THINGS WE
THINK WOULD WORK. ONE OF THE
AREAS IN WHICH WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS A BIT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW OF THE AS I
MENTIONED THE PREPARATION THERE
AND FIGHTS ABOUT THE RECORD OF
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST AREA OF
FRIDAY AND SEE. ONE CONCEPT
THAT'S BEEN FLOATED THERE'S NOT
A COUNCIL SPONSORED PROPOSAL BY
ANY MEANS BECAUSE IT'S DEALING
WITH SICK WITH SUBSTANTIVELY.
BUT OUR EXPERTS BIRDS OF
IDENTIFIED THAT THAT UNDER
SEAQUEST OPPOSED TO MOST.
ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY KIND OF
PROCESS AND YOU HAVE BOTH THE
PUBLIC AGENCY AND THE PETITIONER.
BEING ALLOWED TO PREPARE.
THE RECORD -- WE SEE A LOT OF
DELAY COMING WITH THE PETITIONER
PREPARATION THE RECORD ISSUES IF
IT WAS JUST THE PUBLIC AGENCY
NOT CONSULTED WITH THE NUMBER OF
SICK WITH EXPERT ATTORNEYS
INCLUDING.
ATTORNEYS THAT REPRESENTED THE
WARRIORS AND OTHER LITIGATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE EQUATION AND
THEY DO AGREE THAT THE BIGGEST
AREA OF DELAY.
HAS TO DO WITH FIGHTS OVER THE
RECORD MOTION TO A LARGE AND
CERTIFY THE RECORD IT CETERA.
AND SOONE THING THAT WE THINK
RESPECTFULLY SHOULD BE EXPLORED.
IS THIS ISSUE OF WHETHER WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO ALLOW PETITIONERS
OF THE ABLE TO PREPARE AND
CERTIFY THE RECORD IN THESE
CASES AS OPPOSED TO THE PUBLIC
AGENCY WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENS IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER.
ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY KIND OF
DECISION THAT COULD BE APPEALED
TO COURT VIA A RED THE ISSUE
THERE IS A PUBLIC AGENCY DOESN'T
WANT TAKE ON THAT BURDEN IS THAT.
THERE MAY BE THERE MAY BE COST
ISSUES THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS PART OF THAT AGAIN
IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT A COUNCIL SPONSOR
PROPOSAL BUT WE WE HAVE BEEN
ASKED REPEATEDLY OVER THE YEARS
TO COME UP WITH SOME IDEAS THAT
COULD TRULY STREAMLINE AS
OPPOSED TO THIS APPROACH.
AND THAT'S ONE AREA THAT'S
CERTAINLY WORTH EXPLORING OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHELSEA TO WITH THE
CENTER ON RACE POVERTY IN
ENVIRONMENT.
WE ALSO OPPOSE SB SIXTY SIX
TWENTY ONE FOR SIMILAR REASONS I
STATED EARLIER.
A NORMAL JUSTICE COMMUNITIES
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NOT ONLY.
FACE.
THE HOUSING PRICES IN THAT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
LIVE THE HOUSING PRICES EVERY
DAY -- HOWEVER AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO STRESS THAT SEEK WAS NOT THE
PROBLEM TO HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION.
SOLUTIONS AND CUNNING SYKORA
WILL NOT COME ONE SHOULD NOT
COME FROM THIRTY SOLUTIONS NOT
COME FROM FURTHER WEAKENING THIS
IMPORTANT LAW.
AND IN ESSENCE SB SIX TWENTY ONE
OTHER BILLS THAT WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER TRIES TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
THAT DOES NOT EXIST.
AND I WOULD RECOMMEND.
IN THE COMMUNITY AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES LOOKING INTO.
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL ACTUALLY
PROTECT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AN ALARM TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES.
OF FOR EXAMPLE BY DEEPENING OF
THE AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES -- AND ESPECIALLY
PRIORITIZING HOUSING THAT'S
AFFORDABLE TO EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS REQUIRING
URGING STRONGER TENANT
PROTECTIONS SUCH AS ELIMINATING
RESTRICTIONS ON LOCAL RENT
CONTROL LAWS GUARANTEEING RIGHT
TO COUNSEL IN HOUSING COURT --
ESTABLISHING STRONGER ANTI
DISPLACEMENT LOCAL HIGH
REQUIREMENTS FOR DEVELOPMENT.
CONTINUING TO ENHANCE THE
ENFORCEMENT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HOUSING ELEMENT NOW ON THIS BILL
AND LOOK FOR TRUE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL SUPPORT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR I WILL SAY THAT ON THIS
BILL AND THE NEXT.
ONE BOTH REQUIRE A SIGNIFICANT.
AND AND AND GIVEN THE ABOVE
MARKET -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS.
AND I AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ENGAGING IN DISCUSSION ABOUT
DISPLACEMENT.
ANTI DISPLACEMENT LANGUAGE
BETWEEN CONNECTS OF THE OF OF
ITEM NUMBER ONE IN THE U. S. B.
TWENTY FIVE BUT BUT I THINK
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO THIS
DISPLACEMENT ISSUE.
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE --
BE SENSITIVE TO THAT.
SO -- THAT'S ALL PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AS WELL BUT YES SORRY
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
HELLO TRODDEN ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS -- IN OPPOSITION.
FRIEND ALSO SIERRA CLUB -- I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE A POINT
ON INJUNCTIVE RELIEF THAT I
DISCUSSED EARLIER -- THIS IS
TYPICALLY THE ONLY REMEDY THAT
MANY SIX LETTERS PURSUE -- AND
LIMITING INJUNCTIVE RELIEF WITH
OBVIOUSLY LIMIT WHAT THEY CAN DO
WITH THEIR CASE AND SO.
WITH THAT WE RESPECT WE WILL
OPPOSE.
ERIN RUBBER GONNA BE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
BRIAN THE WIKI WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION.
MATTHEW BIGGER PLAYING
CONSERVATION THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON THE GO BUT
WE SHARE THE CONCERNS -- EXPRESS
YOUR BY THE OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE THE THE RECOMMEND.
STATIONS OF THE THE COMMITTEE
FOR AMENDMENTS WE THINK THOSE
WOULD BE IMPROVEMENTS INDEED BUT
STILL YOU KNOW ARE UNCERTAIN
THAT WOULD REALLY GO FAR ENOUGH
TO ADDRESS THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEMS WITH THE PROPOSAL.
OKAY ANOTHER THING TO CLARIFY
FOR MY FRIEND FROM THE SIERRA
CLUB WE REMOVE THE PROVISIONS
THAT LIMIT INJUNCTIVE RELIEF --
SO THAT'S AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
SELF.
THAT ISSUE -- ELISE'S BEEN
ADDRESSED AS WELL I KNOW
SALUDABLE WORK IN PROGRESS IT'S
ALWAYS MOVING AROUND BUT BROUGHT
TRYING HEREOKAY I ARE YOU A
TWEENER.
WHAT DO YOU HEAR?
YOUR OPPOSITION OKAY ARE YOU
JUST HANGING BACK OKAY.
OKAY FIFTY NG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BY RELIGIOUS ALLIANCE
TO HAVE.
ONLY ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BEFORE BY CRP AND OTHER GROUPS
THAT.
ON THIS BILL IS REALLY NOT GOING
TO ACHIEVE A LEVEL FOUR WHEEL
HOUSING THAT WE REALLY NEED.
ESPECIALLY FOR MANY LOW INCOME
COMMUNICATIVE COLOR THAT ARE
AFRAID THAT THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION IS GOING TO PUSH
THEM OTHER HOMES.
REALLY HOPE NOT WE CAN SEEK WERE.
SHE HAD THE AUTHOR'S INTENSE WE
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION AND SO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
OKAY THIS IS A NOW BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION.
IF YOU.
SURE THE TERM SHEET WITH.
CINEMA CASKEY.
OKAY GREAT -- QUESTIONS
DISCUSSION FIGHTS CONCERNS
ISSUES WE STILL HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE STILL CAN'T CAST A VOTE
OBVIOUSLY BUT HI DO YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THE DISCUSSION
IT'S HAPPENED SO FAR WITH THE
OPPOSITION.
CENTERED.
WELL I WOULD JUST SAY ON THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ISSUE --
CERTAINLY 'M SENSITIVE TO THAT
THAT CONCERN AND AS HE INDICATED
THAT I'VE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT IT [inaudible]
THAT -- INDICATES THAT I'D LIKE
TO SUPPORT ANY KIND OF HIGHER
COSTS THIS WITH HIM AND AND IN
KERR ON THE COURTS -- BUT I ALSO
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE CRITICS
SAY THAT -- THIS IS IN PART OF
THE PROBLEM AT ALL INSIGHTS TO
SUCCEED SHOW A FRACTION OF CASES
THAT ARE EVER FILED ON SEA QUEST.
SO IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
ARGUMENTS THAT.
HAPPENED -- OPPOSITION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE OF THE ISSUE THEY
THERE AREN'T VERY MANY AND THEN
THEY COST A LOT AND THEY CLOG
THE COURTS SO BUT I'M HAPPY TO
WORKING THROUGH TO WORKING
THROUGH THOSE -- THOSE ISSUES.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT -- THE
CHAIR IS CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED
THAT THIS BILL NOW IN ITS
AMENDED FORM -- HAS HIGHER
STANDARDS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
HIGHER STANDARDS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL -- QUALITY -- AND
AT AND I THINK THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THE END IF WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THIS IS A CRISIS IN
OUR STATE.
THAT HOUSING IS A CRISIS ARE
THERE WHILE THE CRITICS MIGHT
SAY THIS DOESN'T DO ENOUGH.
IT'S ALL ABOUT DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN AT EVERY LEVEL TO BE
HELPFUL.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS ARE YOU FOUND A PLACE
SIDE TO MOVE.
ON THE IDEA OF YOU KNOW CREATING
MORE HOUSING FOR WORD ENDING AND
SO IT'S A GOOD DEAL AND I LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS
YOU TAKE THE MMS IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
AND THANK YOU TO STAFF.
WERE OUT WORKING WITH YOU ON THE
ISSUES THAT STILL REMAIN
[inaudible]
MAKOVSKY.
JUST SO I'M CLEAR ON WHAT THE
TERM SHEETS TO THE DEAL LIKE I
GET THE GOLD CERTIFIED TRYING TO
MAKE IT LIKE A B..
NINE HUNDRED THAT'S THAT'S FINE.
WITH REGARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHORS AND POTENTIAL --
ALLOWING SOME MIXED USE PROJECT --
PROJECTS.
CAN YOU CLARIFY THAT FOR ME I'M
SORRY I GOT HERE LATE.
WELL THE ISSUE THAT THEY CAME UP
IN OUR DISCUSSION IS -- YOU KNOW.
WE AT THE THOUGHT HERE IS THAT
WE'VE GOT A GOVERNOR WHO'S MADE
A VERY BOLD -- STATEMENT ABOUT
WANTING TO REALLY ADDRESS THE
HOUSING ISSUES THAT ARE AT PLAY
AND AND YEAH THERE'S A LOT OF
FACTORS AS WE ALL DISCUSSES
NORMALCY BECAUSE YOU KNOW MAYBE.
THIS BABY SECRET BEING BY FAR
TOO MUCH HERE IN THIS DISCUSSION
BUT AT THE AT THE SAME TIME --
WE WE WE REALLY WANNA MAKE SURE
THIS IS FOCUSED ON ON ON HOUSING.
I HAVE A WE ALSO ARE AWARE OF
THE FACT THAT HOUSING PROJECTS
AND YOU KNOW.
PENCIL OUT MUCH.
MUCH BETTER IF THERE'S A CERTAIN
DEGREE MIXED USE AND IN FACT.
IF IF IT'S PROPERLY PLANNED YOU
CAN HAVE A YOU KNOW A MORE
SUSTAINABLE.
SET UP -- YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE ON A WALK TO WORK AND GET
BUY THEIR GROCERIES ETCETERA --
RIGHT THERE NEXT TO IT NEXT TO
WHERE THEY LIVE AND WE WANT TO I
THINK WE SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET A LOT MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY HOUSING
PROJECTS OUT THERE.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT ALLOW FOR
A CERTAIN DEGREE MIXED USE WILL
HELP TO FINANCE THAT WERE OPEN
TO THAT DISCUSSION RIGHT SO THE
PROPHET THERE'S A PROHIBITION
NOW ON MAKES USE.
BUT THE IDEA IS THAT WE MAY
ALLOW SOME EXCUSE WHATEVER THAT
VOLUME IS THAT [inaudible]
FAIR.
WITH REGARD TO THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DAYS JUDICIAL REVIEW.
HI I'VE HEARD ALL THE ANALOGY IS
ABOUT THE NEW BILLIONAIRE --
STADIUM PROJECTS BUT THAT'S ONE
PROJECT.
THIS ONE PROJECT AND IT'S A
JUDICIAL REVIEW THERE'S ONE IN
LA TWO SETS TO PROJECT BUT
THEY'RE SIMPLE REVIEW.
WHEN I READ THE LANGUAGE HERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YES IF
THERE'S SOMEBODY CHALLENGES THE
E. I. R. THEY GET EXPEDITED?
REVIEW THAT'S ONE ISSUE BUT IT'S
FOR ANY OR GRANTING THE APPROVAL
OF THE HOUSING PROJECT.
SO THAT'S A FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT -- SITUATION BECAUSE
NOW YOU HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
TWO CITIES ALL THAT MAY HAVE A I
DID OBJECTION TO THE PROJECT.
AND JUST BECAUSE IT'S A HOUSING
PROJECT.
THEN IT GETS THE THE MAGIC --
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS.
THIS IS THE AM I READING THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT IS THAT WHAT THE
INTENT IS HERE THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANYBODY THAT SAYSTHIS IS A HOUSING PROJECT WE GET.
WE GET TO THE TOP LINE
REGARDLESS WHETHER THE OTHER
PRIORITIES ARE IN THE COURTS THE
TERMS THAT ARE LAID OUT IN THE
BILL IN THE AMENDMENT.
YES.
OKAY.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S A DEAL
BREAKER FOR ME.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT THAT'S I GET
THE ENTHUSIASM THAT PEOPLE HAVE
OVER IT AND I GET THE AND I WILL.
WE'LL DEAL WITH THE ANALOGIES
BETWEEN A SPORTS A BILLION OR
SPORTS CENTER IT'S VERY NICE
VERY GREAT ON TWITTER AND ALL
THAT TYPE OF STUFF BUT IT'S A
DIFFERENT CHALLENGE FOR THE
COURTS TO SAY.
EVERY PROJECT IF WE JUST UP WHAT
WHAT THIS COURT SYSTEMS ARE MADE
THAT WAY FORGET.
FORGET TO SEEK WORK IN ON OTHER
WITH RESPECT TO SENATOR -- THAT
IT WAS A STUDY DONE LAST YEAR
YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT --
POINTED OUT HOW FEW CHALLENGES.
SO -- AND I I WOULD NOTE THAT
WHILE THAT THE A STREAMLINED --
BILLS HAVE BEEN LIMITED WE JUST
DID ONE LAST YEAR FOR OUR
LEGISLATIVE PARKING STRUCTURES
SO [inaudible]
WORTH NOTING [inaudible]
OKAY I'M. ONE OF ONE THING I
WANTED I WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS
ONE AND I MENTIONED TO THE JUDGE
OF RELIEF I'VE JUST TO BE REALLY
FAIR -- IT WAS IN THE HOUSES I
DON'T KNOW THAT I DID GET YOUR
EXPLICIT -- AGREEMENT TO THAT
I'M.
I WILL I WILL SAY THAT BECAUSE
THIS IS GOING TO JUDICIARY WHERE
THE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF QUESTION
WILL BE -- HUGE I'M WILLING --
TO KEEP YOUR COMMITMENT TO THAT
ISSUE BIG AT THIS POINT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT'S GOING
TO BE VERY SERIOUSLY ADDRESSED
OVER JUDICIARY SO OUR COMMITTEE
IS ASKING FOR IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO HOLD YOU TO IT
FROM CANADA RIGHT NOW BUT I
UNDERSTAND BUT I'M.
CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL BE ASKED
TO MAKE THAT COMMITMENT -- IT
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE -- SO JUST
TO CLARIFY -- THE ISSUE STILL
PENDING JUST TO BE FAIR AND I ON
THIS BILL ON ON THIS BILL MAY BE
DIFFERENT OKAY -- THE OTHER I
DID WANT TO ASK YOU THOUGH I DID
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT THE
ISSUE WAS RAISED BY OUR OUR
FRIEND FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WHICH IS THIS ISSUE OF THE FACT
THAT YOU'VE GOT.
ARE YOU KNOW -- ON A COMPLEX
LITIGATION [inaudible]
AND THE COMPLEX LITIGATION OF
THE ONES THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MULTIPLE
CAUSES OF ACTION THAT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE SEQUEL RELATED CAUSE
OF ACTION YOU KNOW NONSTICK
CAUSES OF ACTION -- THOSE NON
SINGLE CAUSE OF ACTION ARE NOT
GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO TWENTY
SEVEN DAY RULE UNDER YOUR BELT.
I'M SO THE IDEA WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO THIS ARGUMENT WHICH I FIND.
FRANKLY AND IN A COMPELLING
RIGHT WHAT WOULD YOU SAY THIS
ARGUMENT THAT.
ANY ANY LITIGATION MANY COMPLEX
LITIGATION WORTH ITS SALT SALT
WILL HAVE -- MULTIPLE CAUSES THE
GATE AT CLEANING ON ON SEA QUEST
AND THIS WILL SPEED UP THE
pPROCESS AT ALL.
WELL I THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'VE REQUESTED -- LIMIT
THAT OPTION BECAUSE YOU'VE
INDICATED.
THAT YOU'D LIKE US TO BE LIMITED
TO NO MORE THAN TWELVE TWO
HUNDRED RESIDENTIAL UNITS.
NOEL I LARGER THAN FIVE ACRES SO
THERE'S LIMITS THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING IN THIS LEGISLATION THAT
I THINK.
MAKES THE LIKELIHOOD OF COMPLEX
LITIGATION MUCH MUCH LESS.
AND THAT THAT OF COURSE ALWAYS
REMAINS A POSSIBILITY ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS GIVE SOME --
GREATER CONFIDENCE TO THE
PRIVATE.
INVESTOR COMMUNITY THAT SAYS DO
I WANT TO GET IN THERE.
AND AND BUILD HOUSING PROJECTS
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABLE IS IT WORTH OF MY
CAPITAL IS THE RISK WORTH IT. TO
DO AND SO.
YOU'VE CREATED SOME BRACKETS
WITHIN THE AMENDMENTS TO THIS
LEGISLATION.
THAT DO LIMIT THE EXPOSURE AT
SOME LEVEL AT BUT IT'S ALWAYS
THERE AND THAT'S THAT GONNA BE
THAT QUESTION AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
WITH THIS TO BECOME LAW IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE THAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR FEELS LIKE THE
RISKS HAVE READ REDUCED ENOUGH
TO HELP.
FUEL THAT HOUSING -- BOOM THAT
WE ALL WANT TO SEE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE AND AND
WE'LL GO ON TO THE CARRIER IS
FALSE ON BEHALF OF CENTER CAP
ERA MYSELF THANK YOU FOR THAT
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND WITH YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND AND YOU KNOW WE
WERE IN A LONG AND AND ARDUOUS
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEARING
YESTERDAY AND AND YOU KNOW PART
PART OF THE HI.
YEAH I I THESE ARE ALL VERY MUCH
WORKS IN PROGRESS AND WE'RE
WE'RE ALL CONVICTS YOU'LL BE
AWARE THE NEXT TO ME WHERE THESE
BILLS ARE HAD IT SO -- WITH THAT
THANK YOU SENATOR AND WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE THE OTHER JOINTLY
AUTHORED BILL -- THIS IS AS WE
TWENTY FIVE ITEM ONE IN YOUR
AGENDAS MEMBERS.
SET A CAREER WHEN YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AND SENATORS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL.
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IMPLEMENTS AN
IMPORTANT STREAMLINING TO SEE
QUALIFICATION BY PROVIDING
CERTAINTY TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PROJECTS FUNDED BY QUALIFIED
OPPORTUNITY ZONE FINES OR OTHER
SPECIFIED PUBLIC FUNDS.
AS YOU WELL KNOW CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE MIDST OF A HOUSING CRISIS
THAN THE COST OF RENTING A HOME
IN CALIFORNIA IS AN ALL TIME
HIGH.
IN MY COMMUNITY IT'S TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENT -- WHICH
USUALLY HOUSES MANY MANY ADULTS
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THAT.
ON IT HOME OWNERSHIP IS ALSO AT
ITS LOWEST RATE SINCE THE
NINETEEN FORTIES AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT THE BENEFIT OF THE
GI BILL HAS BEEN TOTALLY.
ELIMINATED BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
KEPT UP WITH THE WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING FOR TO
MEET OUR WORKFORCE NEEDS.
THIS OBVIOUSLY IS DUE TO A
VARIETY OF FACTORS SUCH AS
INCREASED COST OF LAND MATERIALS
ZONING RESTRICTIONS AND THE
UNCERTAINTY OF LITIGATION
BROUGHT SOMETIMES.
AUSPICIOUSLY UNDERSEA QUOTE.
WELL I VALUE AND SUPPORT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS OF SEA
QUEST AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT BECAUSE I THINK SEQUENCE
SERVES A REALLY IMPORTANT
FUNCTION IN OUR STATE.
AND IT T REALLY GIVES
COMMUNITIES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT THE PROJECT CAN YOU
DECIDE HOW TO MITIGATE ANY
IMPACTS.
IT'S BEEN OFTEN USED BY NIMBIS
TO SLOW STALL FRUSTRATE AND
OFTEN KILL PROJECTS FOR REASONS
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
INSUFFICIENT ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION.
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
POINT IN MY REGION I PROBABLY
READ EVERY E. I. ARE -- IN THAT
IN THIS IN SALINAS OVER THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS -- INCLUDING MOST
OF THE COUNTY COUNTY.
AT E. IRISES WELL -- IT THAT DAY
SYKORA THREAD OF SEQUEL --
LITIGATION OR LITIGATION HAS
BEEN -- THREATENED ON ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT -- IN MY REGION AND THAT
HAS DRASTICALLY INCREASED THE
COST OFHOUSING -- FOR LOCAL
RESIDENTS UNFORTUNATELY THE
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS PREVAILING
DELAYING OR HALTING MANY HOUSING
PROJECTS INCLUDING.
ONE OF THE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITIES PROJECT IN REDWOOD
CITY THE BAY AREA'S HEAVILY
HOUSING IMPACTS ON ON THE
PENINSULA.
I'M COMMITTED TO INCREASING THE
HOUSE OF HOUSING SUPPLY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO BRING
AFFORDABILITY TO THE HOUSING
MARKET.
AND I'M ALSO COMMITTED TO
TACKLING DECADES OF INSUFFERABLE
POVERTY FOR THE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE BLIGHTED
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED BY THE
GOVERNOR BROWN ADMINISTRATION.
AS OUR CALIFORNIA'S POOREST JOB
POOR COMMUNITIES ARE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
PRIVATE PRIVATE INVESTORS WILL
BE POURING BILLIONS OF CAPITAL
ESTIMATED TO BE UP TO SEVEN
TRILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
NATION'S POOREST NEIGHBORHOODS
THROUGHOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES ON
FUNDS.
CALIFORNIA IS COMPETING WITH
EVERY OTHER STATE FOR THESE
FUNDS AND NEEDS TO GIVE OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES EVERY TOOL TO
GAIN A COMPETITIVE.
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE S. B.
TWENTY FIVE DOES NOT COST THE
STATE ANY DIRECT FUNDS BUT IT
WILL HELP OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO PACKAGE THEIR OWN
OPPORTUNITIES ON PROJECTS.
INTO ATTRACTIVE COMMUNITY
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK TO HELP
SHAPE IS B. TWENTY FIVE AND EAT
AND EVEN STRONGER FRAMEWORK.
FIRST SEQUEL LITIGATION REFORM
THE THOUGHTFUL COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS RAISES MANY PAUL MANY
POINTS IN THERE THERE'S TOO MANY
TO KIND OF GO THROUGH THIS --
TODAY BUT I'M ABLE TO DISCUSS A
FEW OF THOSE CONCERNS WITH THE
CHAIR I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO TO
MANY.
I WISH WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THEM AND TALK ABOUT IT.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THAT EFFORT THROUGH AND I
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS -- AND COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THE DETAILS OF SOME
OF THOSE AS THE BILL PROCEEDED
TO GETS OUT OF EQ TODAY -- IN
PARTICULAR AND THE THAT THE
NUMBERS AND THEY NEED TO WORK IN
THE REAL WORLD AND I WANT TO BE
ABLE -- TO TO TALK WITH THE THAT --
BUILDING COMMUNICABLE HOUSING
PERCENT GM YEAH THE PRESENTING
THE PERCENTAGE IN THE AM I AND
AND THE REASON.
IS I I'M YES IS IS AND I YOU
KNOW HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND
SOME TIME.
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
WITH -- DEVELOPERS THAT ARE
BUILT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
AND PART OF THE CHALLENGE IT
THIS REALLY GETS TO THE ROOT OF
THE ISSUE IS THAT WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY LOOK OVER A FIVE OR A TEN
YEAR HORIZON.
THEY THEY HAVE TO BUY THE
PROPERTY TODAY TO TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD.
X. NUMBER OF YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
SO IF THEY'RE BUILDING TODAY
THEY BOUGHT THE PROPERTY QUITE A
BIT AGO AND WHAT THEY LOOK AT IS
WHAT IS THE RISK IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT WHEN THEY WHEN THEY ARE --
AND AT PUTTING TOGETHER THE
MONEY TO MAKE THE INVESTMENTS --
CAN I DO IT EASIER AND MAKE A
BETTER RATE OF RETURN SOMEWHERE
ELSE OR IS THE BURDEN INTO OF
DOING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA SO
MUCH THAT I CAN I'M GONNA KEEP A
LIMITED SUPPLY.
OF LAND AND INVESTMENT MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS.
REALLY IT'S A BIGGER PICTURE
WHICH IS ASCERTAIN WHAT THE RISK
IS OF INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA
AND AND PART OF THE PART OF THIS
IS TO REDUCE THAT RISK.
SO THAT THEY SEE A WAITING TO BE
ABLE -- TO MOVE PROJECTS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND NOT BE HELD UP
FOR YEARS -- BECAUSE OF
LITIGATION THAT -- THEY HAVE NO
CONTROL CONTROL OVER AND THAT
ULTIMATELY MAY END UP BEING
RESOLVED BUT BUT IN THE MEANTIME
THEY'RE NOT BUILDING SO THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT -- THAT
YOUR STAFF AND YOU HAVE DONE
BECAUSE WITHOUT IT IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN IMPOSSIBLE TO REALLY MAKE
IT MOVE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE HERE TODAY.
WITH ME IS -- MARINE SIT DOWN
AND FROM THE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY GREATER SAN FRANCISCO
AND HOT HOLLY FROM MANY IT HAS
TO SUPPLY SOME LIGHT HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND MY CO CHAIR
WITH ME TODAY MY CO.
AUTHOR HERO PILOT CO PILOT.
AND I'LL BE BRIEF BECAUSE THE
CENTER HAVE A ROSE AND A GREAT
JOB OF LAYING OUT THE REASONS
FOR THIS EXCEPTIONAL BILL THAT --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME SAID VERY
CLEARLY THAT FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES OWN PROGRAMS ARE
POTENTIALLY TRANSFORMATIVE. FOR
OUR POOREST COMMUNITIES AND THIS
BILL DOES CREATE NEW STREAMLINED
SEQUEL LITIGATION FRAMER SO
INVESTORS INVESTORS IN
OPPORTUNITIES ON'S WILL KNOW
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PROJECTS
HURTING ARE GONNA GET A
STRINGENT ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
BUT THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE
UNNECESSARILY DELAY.
SO WE HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO SHAPE THE A NEW WAVE OF
DEVELOPMENT -- THAT WOULD COME
THROUGH OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND
I'M PLEASED TO JOIN -- IN
SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN NOT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S MARIN SAID ON AND I'M THE
CEO OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
GREATER SAN FRANCISCO I'M ALSO
THE VICE CHAIR OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE VIEWS OF FORTY
ONE AFFILIATES.
ACROSS THE DEPTH AND BREADTH OF
OUR STATE.
HABITAT PROVIDES A UNIQUE AND
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY FOR FAMILIES.
AS A HOME A HOME AT ZERO DOWN
PAYMENT 0% INTEREST AND A THIRTY
YEAR MORTGAGE WHICH MONTHLY
PAYMENT SAT AT NO MORE THAN 30%
OF OUR HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
IN OUR PARTICULAR HABITAT OVER
80% OF OUR HOMES HAVE GONE TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IN LIEU OF A DOWN PAYMENT FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS.
PUT AS FIVE HUNDRED HOURS OF
SWEAT EQUITY TO BUILD THEIR
FUTURE HOMES AND HOME OF THEIR
NEIGHBORS WITH NO INTEREST ON
THEIR MORTGAGE FAMILY START
SAVING AS HOMEOWNERS.
FROM DAY ONE IN THEIR HABITAT
HOMES.
I'M DELIGHTED TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING ALONGSIDE SENATOR
CAFIERO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
AND FOR SICK WITH SENATOR GLAZER
AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SB
TWENTY FIVE IN ITS ATTEMPT TO
MAKE THE APPLICATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA VITAMIN A QUALITY ACT
SIMPLER AND FAIRER.
I'M ALSO HERE TO PUT A HUMAN
FACE ON THIS DILEMMA.
HABITAT KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT
SECRET IS TO MAINTAIN AND
PROTECT OUR STATES AND REBEL AND
BEAUTIFUL NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE HOW THE SCALE AND
SCOPE OF THE APPLICATION ON THE
GROUND HAS A CHILLING EFFECT ON
THE ABILITY OF DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR
WORKING FAMILIES. FOR NEARLY
SIXTEEN MONTHS HABITAT.
THE HABITAT DEVELOPMENT AND I
THINK YOU HAVE A PICTURE OF IT
IN FRONT OF YOU IT'S VERY
BEAUTIFUL -- ON JEFFERSON AVENUE
IN DOWNTOWN REDWOOD CITY STUDENT
WOULD NEEDLESSLY STALLED AS WE
FOUGHT A BASELESS.
LAWSUIT FROM OUR NEIGHBORS.
THIS WAS FILED BY LOCAL BUSINESS
WHO HAD A TRACK RECORD OF
INITIATING SEQUEL LITIGATION.
TWENTY LOCAL FAMILIES WITH
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES BETWEEN FORTY
AND 80% OF AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
SHOULD BE GETTING READY TO MOVE
INTO THESE HOMES TODAY.
BUT INSTEAD THIS PROJECT WAS
DELAYED IN AN EFFORT TO RAISE
THE COST TO THE POINT.
WHERE THE PROJECT WOULD STOP?
WELL I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
WE'RE NEARLY READY TO SEND OUT
INVITATIONS TO OUR GROUND
BREAKING IT'S BEEN A LONG HARD
FOUGHT EFFORT TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF BEHIND
SCHEDULE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT BY THE TIME WE SERVE WE
WERE SERVED WITH THE LAWSUIT THE
PROJECT HAD ALREADY HAD ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
METICULOUSLY REVIEWED.
NONE THE LESS AND NONE THE LESS.
OOPS MY MY RUN PATIENT.
AND UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
PLANNING COMMISSION AND THE CITY
COUNCIL.
THE LAWSUIT CAME IN LATE BASED
ON LATE COMMENTS.
WE WERE LUCKY AS WE WERE ABLE TO
SETTLE ON A VERY FAVORABLE TERMS
WHICH IMPORTANTLY DID NOT
REQUIRE US. TO WE HAD ALREADY
REDUCED THE NUMBERS OF HOMES
THROUGH OUR CONVERSATIONS OVER
TIME.
THIS WAS PROBABLY FOR THREE
REASONS ONE BECAUSE OF THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF HABITAT
HOMEOWNERS IN THE COMMUNITY
THERE WERE FIFTY FOUR ALREADY
THERE.
HUNDREDS OF VOLUNTEERS.
AND HUNDREDS OF SUPPORTERS AND
DONORS WHO SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HABIT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND BECAUSE THEY GOT THERE IS
THEY STILL WANT OTHERS TO GET
THERE. TWO BECAUSE OF THE PRO
BONO COUNSEL A LAW FIRM THAT WAS
COMMITTED TO TAKING OUR
OPPONENTS IN LITIGATION ON THE
WAY TO TRIAL.
AND THREE BECAUSE OF THE
STRENGTH OF THE HABITAT BRAND
WHICH MEANT THAT WE COULD SPEAK
OUT LOUDLY AND IN PUBLIC ABOUT
THE INJUSTICE.
EVIDENT IN THE APPLICATION OF
THE WELL INTENTIONED BUT ABUSE
LAW.
NONE THE LESS THE COST HAD
ESCALATED BY THEN TO MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTSUM
IN THE OVERHEATED BAY AREA
HOUSING MARKET.
ALL FOR A DOWNTOWN DEVELOPMENT
THE FEATURED NO LEGITIMATE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS. FOR TOO
MANY AFFORDABLE DEVELOPERS IN
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LAWSUITS OF THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS SIMPLY BY
ISSUING A LAWSUIT THE PLAINTIFF
CAN WREAK HAVOC ON A PROJECT.
AND OFTEN THEY'RE ABLE TO
EXTRACT SUBSTANTIAL CONCESSIONS
FROM DEVELOPERS.
DEVELOPERS EITHER FINANCIAL OR
REDUCED NUMBERS OF HOMES OR MANY
TIMES BOTH.
AND BY DEVELOPERS I MEAN HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY A DECADE STRONG
NONPROFIT THAT PUTS FAMILIES
FIRST.
NOT SOMEONE BUILDING A BALLPARK.
MORE TO THE POINT THE MERE
THREAT OF CIVIL LITIGATION HAS A
REAL IMPAT ON THOSE MARGINAL
DEVELOPMENTS NOT UNDERTAKING AT
ALL BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT.
RENDERS THEM ECONOMICALLY
UNREALISTIC AT THE OUTSET.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS LAWSUIT WOULD
SIMPLY HAVE BLOWN ANY OTHER
AFFORDABLE ABOUT FOR OUT OF THE
WATER WE WERE EXTREMELY
FORTUNATE.
THAT'S WHY THE SENSIBLE REFORMS
OF SICK WILL INDICATION LIKE
THOSE PROPOSED IN SB TWENTY FIVE
WE'LL HAVE SUCH AN ENORMOUS
IMPACT ON THE NUMBER OF HOMES
THAT CAN BE BUILT. FOR WORKING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA WITH YOUR
PERMISSION MISTER CHAIR I WANTED
TO BRIEFLY COVER SOME OF THE
DETAILS OF THE THE COMMITTEE MAY
BE CONSIDERING YOU HAVE AS
BRIEFLY AS YOU CAN OKAY I'LL GO
REALLY BRIEF THEN.
AND I'LL SAY -- WE JUST AREN'T
REALLY ANSWER APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
AND WE SUPPORT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE THERE AND I
WON'T GO THROUGH THEM -- BUT
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT BY -- WE
WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ACCESS TO SEEK WELL FOR THE FOR
THE LEAD CERTIFICATION FOR THE
SUNSET CLAUSE -- AND FOR THE
AVAILABILITY OF INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF THESE PROJECTS NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROCESS
PROGRESS AND WE NEED THEM TO NOT
BE STOPPED MISTER CHAIRMAN
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY GROUP
CALIFORNIA IS GREAT FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION.
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
OKAY I ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO WIN
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING YELLING EVER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT.
IF THOSE CALIFORNIA PARMA
CESSATION HAPPENS FOR ANOTHER
MEASURE TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THANK YOU.
CASSIE GILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION [inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
RIGHT RIGHT LA COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION BIZ FED IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING A STEVE CRUISE ON
BEHALF OF WESTFIELD WE DID
SUBMIT A LETTER OF OF SUPPORT
AND I JUST WENT OVER THE SUPPORT
OF FERMENTED POSITION I'D.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK
THAT SENATOR KIRBY ROAD CENTER
WAGER DOING -- WHAT WE WERE --
LOOKING AT OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE IS IS FOCUSED ON
HAVING PARAMETERS AROUND THE
BILL THE WESTFIELD AS A
DEVELOPER OF MAJOR SHOPPING
CENTERS ACROSS THE WORLD WITH
MANY LOCATIONS IN OUR MAJOR
CITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA THEY MOVED IN THE
DIRECTION OF DEVELOPING -- LOT
OF MIXED USE DEVELOPMENTS AND
TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES THE CENTER SAID TO
BUILD VILLAGES WHERE FOLKS CAN
LIVE AND WORK AND REDUCE -- GET
A RATHER VEHICLES AND AND SO AS
WE DO THAT -- YOU KNOW ARE
ENCOUNTERING THE CHALLENGES --
TO THESE PROJECTS AND SO.
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS ARE A GOOD
START A GOOD MEASUREMENT OF
IDENTIFYING THESE HISTORICALLY --
DISTRESSED COMMUNITIES OTHER
OTHERS -- LOCATIONS THAT HAS
EARNED THAT DESIGNATION AND HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AREAS IN NEED OF
INCENTIVES AND SO AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD.
WE LIKE TO AT LEAST CONSIDER --
SOME OF THE LOCATIONS WHETHER
THERE.
ENTERPRISE ZONES ARE FORMER
REDEVELOPING AREAS OF SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT LOOK AT THESE
ADDITIONAL AREAS TO HELP BRING --
THESE PROJECTS -- FOR IT SO SHE
THE SUPPORT AND WONDER REGISTER
THAT WITH THE COMEDIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I MEAN THAT.
YOU GOT IT.
YEAH NEWS THAT.
MAY BE DIFFERENT WELL -- BUT BUT
CERTAINLY I'VE I'VE I'VE ENJOYED
SPEAKING WITH YOU AND AND THERE
THERE'S A WHOLE SET OF GONNA
BLIGHT ISSUES I THINK THEY'RE
VALUABLE MPORTANT TALK ABOUT.
ON THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THE CHAIR NOTICES THE PRESENCE
OF A QUORUM SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM -- SECRETARY
[inaudible]
ILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
PRESENT [inaudible]
CASKEY [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
YES I THINK YEAH.
RIGHT OKAY -- NOW JUST TO THERE
WAS A COMMENT MADE -- BY -- THE
WITNESS FOR THE SHOT AFTER
HABITAT ABOUT INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
I WILL SAY THAT WE DID GET
EXPLICIT.
AGREEMENT TO REMOVE THE
LIMITATION ON INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
AT LEAST IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
BILL-- SO.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO EXPLORE
IT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO KEEP
TALKING BUT AND THAT'S IT AMANDA
IT'S BEEN AGREED.
TO OKAY OTHER FOLKS YOU WANNA
RAISE CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE DOOR.
YEAH.
REMEMBERS THEM PHONE FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL -- IN ADDITION
TO THE REASONS.
FOR OPPOSITION THAT WE TESTIFIED
TO ON THE EARLIER TWO BILLS
THERE IS ONE UNIQUE FEATURE
ABOUT THIS BILL THAT'S REALLY
PROBLEMATIC FROM A COURT
WORKABILITY STANDPOINT.
SO WE'RE CONCERNED WITH THE
RECENT ADDITION IN THE BILL.
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT THE COURT
FROM ACCEPTING FOR FILING AN
ACTION FROM A PARTY THAT FELL TO
PROVIDE THE LEAD AGENCY IN THE
REAL PARTY IN INTEREST A TEN DAY
NOTICE OF INTENT TO SUE.
AND THE COURT CLERKS.
PERFORM MINISTERIAL DUTIES AND
ACCEPTING FILINGS THEY ARE NOT
IN A POSITION TO MAKE A LEGAL
DETERMINATION WHETHER PROPER
NOTICE WAS OR WAS NOT.
GIVENIN A PARTICULAR CASE THERE
ARE OTHER WAYS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE THAT DON'T PRESENT.
THE COURT WORKABILITY PROBLEM SO
WE WOULD VERY RESPECTFULLY ASK
THIS IS YOUR NEGOTIATING
MEHMET'S REQUEST THAT THIS
PARTICULAR PROVISION BE REMOVED
WE CAN TALK ABOUT ALTERNATIVE
WAYS THAT THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED.
THAT'S A REALLY PROBLEMATIC
PROVISION FROM A COURT
WORKABILITY STANDPOINT.
AND IN ADDITION TO THE OTHER
REASONS FOR OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU I SEE THAT AUTHOR NODDING --
OR THIS WITH A CO AUTHOR JOIN
OTHER.
HI AND I I WILL MAKE SURE THAT
OUR STAFFS WORK WITH JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON THAT TOO GHOST INC
YOU.
THANK YOU CHELSEA TO THE CENTER
ON RACE POVERTY ENVIRONMENT WE
POSED AS BE -- TWENTY FIVE FOR
MANY OF THE REASONS WE STAYED IN
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE PREVIOUS
BILLS -- SIX TWENTY ONE A THREE
EIGHTY FOUR AND ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL GOES FAR BEYOND
HOUSING.
WITH.
LIMIT OF PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
AND JUDICIAL RELIEF FOR A WIDE
VARIETY OF PROJECTS THAT CAN
HAVE DETRIMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
AND HEALTH IMPACTS.
IN THE BY THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SYRUPY WORKS --
PRIMARILY IN THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND KERN COUNTY
INTO LARRY COUNTIES WITH LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
THESE COMMUNITIES -- AS MOST
EVERYONE IS WELL AWARE OF OUR
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED WITH
BOTH POLLUTION AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC FACTORS.
AND EVEN THOUGH THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE BLIGHTED THEY'RE
NOT JUST -- OPENING ARMS FOR ANY
KIND OF INVESTMENT ESPECIALLY
NOT INVESTMENTS THAT COULD
DIRECTLY HARM THE HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENT OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO.
I UNDERSTAND THERE MANY
AMENDMENTS THAT RECENTLY --
TAKEN PLACE SO THIS MIGHT BE
MOVED BUT AS AS FAR AS I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL WITH ITS.
APPEAL APPLY A BUNCH OF A
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS IN
PARTICULAR CONCERNING IS THE
FEDERAL PERTINI FUN IT SEEMS TO
BE ABLE.
TO INVEST VIRTUALLY ANY TYPE OF
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE INVESTMENTS
FROM WAREHOUSES TO LARGE
WASTEWATER FACILITIES INTO THESE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES YEAH THAT
WAS OUR CONCERN TO AS WRITTEN
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE HAVE
NOW NEAR TE BILL.
JUST A HOUSING AND TRANSIT
PROJECTS.
ARE CELEBRATED AS WRITTEN
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
OUR OKAY THERE IS THERE IS THE
ONE ISSUE IS.
PARTICULAR TYPES OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS IN OPPORTUNITIES ON
SO WE HAVE.
TO GET THAT CLARIFIED BUT BUT AT
LEAST FOR NON OPPORTUNITIES ON
SITUATIONS IT'S IT IS ONLY WE'RE
ONLY TALK ABOUT HOUSING IN
TRANSIT BY ALL THESE THINGS HAVE
TO BE AT LEAST PUB PARTLY
PUBLICLY FUNDED -- FOR ANYTHING
TO BE COVERED UNDER AS WE TWENTY
FIVE BUT THE ONE THING I THINK
WE NEED TO ZERO IN ON WHICH IS
THE ONE WITH AN AMENDMENT.
ALSO INCLUDE THE STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT FUNDS AS WELL BECAUSE
THEY ALSO THOSE ALSO APPLY.
TO NON HOUSING PROJECTS LIKE
WASTEWATER FACILITIES IN
BROWNFIELD REMEDIATION.
YEAH THE MEMONS [inaudible]
DOES.
I HOUSING PROJECTS FUNDED BY
THOSE ENTITIES YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IT I I BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT I I IT'S
HARD I KNOW FOR A LOT OF STRESS
YOU OUT OF THE ADVOCATES -- WHO?
THERE'S NO QUESTION IT'S BETWEEN
FIVE AS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN WAS
[inaudible]
EXTRAORDINARILY BROAD.
AND IT HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMITED BUT I I UNDERSTAND THAT
KIND OF YOU GUYS ARE ALL
STRUGGLING.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT EXACTLY --
IT'S COVERING ALSO IN IRAQ CLOSE
QUICKLY PLEASE YEAH A COUPLE OF
THE THE LIMITATION SIZE BEFORE
TWENTY FIVE PROPOSES -- PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION REALLY UNDERMINING
THAT KEY FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENT OF
C. QUOTA I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
THAT IT WOULD MAKE IT VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES PROTECT THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
OF IF THEY CANNOT SUBMIT
COMMENTS LATE BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES THEY DO NOT EVEN FIND OUT
ABOUT PROJECTS ON TOP HAS THE
COMMON DEADLINE.
AND SOMETIMES AFTER THE PROJECTS
APPROVED FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS EVEN AT THE COMMUNITIES
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO ACTIVELY
MONITOR PROJECT PROPOSALS.
AND ADDITIONALLY -- THE BILL
PROPOSES AS A PREVIOUSLY STATED
TO REQUIRE PARTY TO NOTIFY THE
AGENCY OR ELSE FORFEIT THEIR
RIGHT TO SUE AND THAT'S ANOTHER
HUGE.
A HURDLE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES TOGETHER
EQUITABLE RELIEF FOR TO BE HEARD
IN COURT THAT THEY DESERVE THESE
PROJECTS SO WE ARE INJURED NOVO
ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIM STONE A STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHO SUPPORT.
AT SEQUESTERING MINING
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD INCREASE
HOUSING AND OTHER BUILDINGS BUT
THERE WERE TWO SPECIFIC LABOR
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT
WOULD -- AT DISADVANTAGE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS MEMBERS AS A COMPS
PAIRED TO UNION CONTRACTORS
THERE'S AN EXEMPTION IF THERE'S
A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT FOR
THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENT.
IN AN EXEMPTION FOR LABOR
COMPLIANCE RECORD KEEPING IF
THERE'S A PROJECT.
LABOR AGREEMENT THOSE AGREEMENTS
DISADVANTAGE OUR MEMBERS AND SO
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANKS.
ERIN RUBBER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
ALIGNED WIT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND ASKED TO BE INVOLVED
IN ANY TALKS WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
AND FIXING THAT ONE ISSUE YES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TELLER TRITON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS AN OPPOSITION -- BRENNAN
DAWSO ABOVE A SIERRA CLUB IN
OPPOSITION OF ONE THING I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW I'M NOT SURE IF
THIS WAS TALKED ABOUT IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT AS WELL.
BUT ALTHOUGH THIS BILL TAKES
SOME PROVISIONS FOR MAYBE NINE
HUNDRED SP -- AS WE SEVEN FORTY
THREE THIS WILL ACTUALLY EXPAND
THE TYPES OF CASES IN THAT THOSE
TWO BILLS ACTUALLY REFERRED TO
YOU ONLY E. I. OURS IN THIS BILL
FOR SENEC DECKS AS WELL AS IN
THE NINETIES.
AND SO THAT OBVIOUSLY EXPAND THE
TYPES OF CASES THAT WOULD
RECEIVE EXPEDITED ADMINISTRATIVE
AND JUDICIAL REVIEW AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S CLEARLY --
ISSUE WITH US AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE MEMBERS AS FROM WHAT WE'VE
HEARD AND SO THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
ABOUT ESPECIALLY IN OUR POSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO CREDIT WITH A
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WE TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
DRAFTED WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S HARD WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALTHOUGH WE'RE
READING TO REVIEW LANGUAGE AND
WILL.
PROCEED ACCORDINGLY I THINK YOU
HAVE.
AFTERNOON MICHAEL CLAIBORNE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS AND WILL
DEFINITELY REVIEW THOSE.
BUT AS WRITTEN WERE CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL WOULD FURTHER
RESTRICT THE ALREADY LIMITED
ABILITY OF COMMUNITIES TO WEIGH
IN ON PROJECTS THAT COULD IMPACT
THEIR ENVIRONMENT AND
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND FOR THAT REASON OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
HI TIFFANY IN WITH CALIFORNIA
VINYL JUST SOMEONE ANSWERS TO
HOW WE ARE ALSO OPPOSING THIS
BILL TODAY BECAUSE AGAIN.
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TO BUILD MORE HOUSING WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION TO WEAKEN SYKORA.
ANSWER MY PROJECTS AND WE
DEFINITELY ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY ITS EUROPEAN LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL ABOUT PUBLIC REVIEW
PERIOD THANK YOU.
MATTHEW BIGGER PLANE
CONSERVATION THE WEEK TO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HAND OF THE
AUTHOR'S BUT ARE OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED APPROACH.
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT --
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AMENDMENT
BY THE COMMITTEE THOUGH I'M A
LITTLE UNCLEAR AS TO WHAT MA'AM.
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN AGREED TO
AT THIS POINT WE THINK THOSE ARE
INDEED IMPROVEMENTS BUT AGAIN
DID NOT ADDRESS.
THE THE FUNDAMENTAL WHAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY PROBLEMATIC ABOUT
THE PROPOSED APPROACH TO
EXPEDITED REVIEW [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOUR NAME RHINO WIKI WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
WON'T REPEAT ANYTHING THAT WAS
SAID IN THE PREVIOUS THREE BELLS --
EXCEPT THAT WE DO.
APPRECIATE THE INTENTIONS OF
THESE PAST TWO BILLS TWENTY FIVE
AND SIX TWENTY ONE AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE APPROACH AND THE
AND THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY.
THE COMMITTEE BUT AS ONE VERY
QUICK COMMENT AND THAT IS THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
WHICH IS INVOLVED IN A LOT OF
SEQUELS LAWSUITS OVER THE YEARS.
HAS THREE TIMES IN THE PAST
TWELVE YEARS BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS BUILDING IN MONTHS LONG
FULL ON DISCUSSIONS OF HOW DO WE
EXPEDITE THE SO THAT THERE IS SO
THAT AT SEA WAS NOT.
SLOWING DOWN BOGGING DOWN COURTS
AND AND AND PROJECTS.
AND THE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY
LIMIT ITSELF IS NOT NECESSARILY
AN ISSUE AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE VERY MUCH BEEN WILLING
TO APPROACH IN THE PAST.
BUT THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN WITH IN
THE CONTEXT OF A FULL PACKAGE A
DISCUSSION COMPREHENSIVE
DISCUSSION OF ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT HAVE TO BE-ADDRESSED IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT
WORK AND MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
COM NONE OF THOSE PACKAGES EVER
CAME TO FRUITION BECAUSE IT WAS
HONESTLY THE POLITICALLY
DIFFICULT FOR ALL OF THE PARTIES
INVOLVED BUT EVERYBODY WAS THERE
FROM.
THE DEVELOPERS OVER TO THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
TYPES ALL ALL AROUND THE TAKE.
TABLE AND IT IT IT IS A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION BUT IN
ORDER TO MAKE THAT SORT OF THING
WORK IT DOES REQUIRE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PIECES SOME OF WHICH
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT ALREADY TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH WELL I MEAN FOR THE FOR
EITHER THESE BILLS.
TO HAVE A PRAYER OF OF SEEING
THE LIGHT OF DAY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK YOU THERE'S
GOING TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION IS
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE PLACE.
LET ME LET ME POINT OUT -- JUST
TO CLARIFY TWO THINGS AND I I I
SHIPMENTS CONFUSION -- ON PAGE
THIRTEEN SO MUCH FOR MY FRIEND
FROM THE CENTER [inaudible]
FROM THE NOW WHAT YES MY FAVOR
THE PARTY ON ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF
THE ANALYSIS I THINK IT
ADDRESSES THE CONCERN THAT YOU
HAVE -- WHICH THIS MAN HAS BEEN
ACCEPTED -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING -- THE COMMITTEE
MAY WISH TO AMEND THE BILL TO
INCLUDE THE ELECTRONIC
AVAILABILITY DOCUMENTS CLEAN
DOCUMENTS SUBMITTED TO OUR
RELIED ON BY THE LEAD AGENCY.
THE OPPOSITION LEADERS YOU TO
CONSIDER COMMENTS SUBMITTED
AFTER THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
WHICH IS THE ISSUE RAISED AND
MEDIATION PROVISIONS IN SB
TWENTY FIVE TO REMAIN CONSISTENT
PRIOR EXPEDITED MINISTER REVIEW
LEGISLATION.
THAT I THINK ADDRESSES THE ISSUE
THAT WAS RAISED.
BY OUR FRIEND OVER HERE THE
OTHER THING IS.
THAT.
ELISE RESCUE TWENTY FIVE ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
ANALYSIS HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED BY
THE AUTHOR THE ONLY COPY I IS.
THAT WERE WORKING ON THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A. M. I.
PERCENTAGE MIX.
BUT BUT BUT EYOND THAT ONE
ISSUE.
ARE THE BY THE WAY THE THE THE
FORMER HOUSING IN MY PRESENTS
MAKES JUST FOR OPPORTUNITIES
OWNED HOUSING PROJECTS AS FOR
THOSE.
THAT PORTION OF THE ISSUES A
COVERED BY THE HOUSE BUT
EVERYTHING ELSE HAS BEEN
ACCEPTED AS SUBMITTED BY THE
COMMITTEE -- AND AS ARTICULATE
ANALYSIS BY THE AUTHOR -- SO.
THERE WE ARE OKAY -- SO THE ITEM
IS NOW BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION AND I
AND AND YOU KNOW I OBVIOUSLY
MEMBERS OUT ONE ADDITIONAL --
CLARIFICATION ON A MAN'S OR WHAT
EXACTLY WERE PROVING I'M WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY TO HELP WITH THAT --
TOO BUT I WOULD THINK YOU HAVE
THE SAME CONCERNS.
SENATOR THE YOU HAD ON A LAST
ALL RIGHT THERE MY ISSUES HAVE
BEEN CHANGED YEAH OKAY.
I THOUGHTS CONSIDERATIONS.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY ONCE AGAIN
THIS IS HEADING STRAIGHT TO THE
JUDICIARY IF IF APPROVED OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND AND A LOT OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
ABOUT PROCESS IN THE COURTS I
WILL CERTAINLY BE FULLY VETTED
THERE -- IN THIS CASE THE AUTHOR
HAS ACCEPTED THE REMOVAL OF
LIMITATION TO INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
EXPLICITLY.
I SO. FOR THAT CONCERN THAT HAS
BEEN ADDRESSED FOR RESCUE.
TWENTY FIVE I'VE IF IF.
YOU'D LIKE [inaudible]
TO AT WELL YEAH IS THAT THE
CENTER STONE GONNA MOVE THIS.
BILL OKAY I BUT IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS HERE
TODAY BOTH THE THOSE IN SUPPORT
IN THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
THE BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO
SOLVE EVERY SINGLE HOUSING ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S REALLY FOCUSED
ON TRYING TO GAIN SOME CERTAINTY
IN ON IN THE IN THE BUILDING
COMMUNITY AS I SAID BEFORE.
APPRECIATE YOUR OUTLINING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I TOOK BCAUSE I
THINK THE ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION ISSUES.
IN PARTICULAR RESTORING SB SEVEN
FORTY THREE LANGUAGE AND THEN
THAT REMOVING THE LIMITATION ON
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF AND THEN ALSO
THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
THIS IS A PROGRAM AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THIS FOR SEVEN YEARS --
BUT HAVING A INFORMATION
REPORTED -- TO PR I THINK IS A
REAL GOOD WAY OF GETTING DATA.
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT HOW THIS IS
USED IN AND WHETHER IT SHOULD BE
EXTENDED OR NOT SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFULNESS
THAT'S GONE INTO HELPING US TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER -- AND I
HOPE TO HAVE YOU KNOW AS AS THIS
BILL PROCEEDS I HOPE IT WILL GET
MORE THAT THE LINE FOR THE
OPPOSITION MOVES OVER TO THE
LINE FOR THE SUPPORT IF AND SO I
I I YEAH I REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORK ON THIS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU THESE
BILLS ARE.
WORKS IN PROGRESS ALWAYS BUT AND
BUT BUT BUT I I AND I I I WANNA
SEE PERSONALLY HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO ME THAT -- YOU DO SERIOUS
WORK WITH THE FOLKS RAISE
CONCERNS.
I AND I ALSO WANTED JUST ITERATE
GIVEN HOW COMPLEX -- AND AND THE
THESE BILLS ARE THAT WE DO WANT
TO RETAIN THE RIGHT TO BRING
THAT THE BILLS BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE -- AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD TO THE PROCESS BUT WITH
THAT I'M I'M I'M HAPPY TO VOTE
FOR TODAY -- THE ITEMS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTERSTONE AND SIX OF
HIS COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. TWENTY
FIVE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
ALAN HI ALAN HI BAIT
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE STONE I Y. CASKEY.
I CASKEY NO CRAP SO WE'LL HOLD
THAT OPEN THE DOOR. FOR THE
CONSIDERATION FOR THE FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS AND ON AND LET'S
NOW TURN TO YOUR ITEMS.
SIX THIS IS SP -- SIX SIXTY NINE
RELATING TO SAVE TRICKING WATER
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE SECRET
DISCUSSIONS.
LOTS MORE TO DO.
MOTION ON SIX TWENTY ONE RIGHT
JUST TO BE CLEAR THERE HAS AN I
MEAN WE'RE GONNA TEAR FROM
CENTER STONE IF HE'S INTERESTED
IN.
PROVIDING OKAY -- THE ITEM SIX
TWENTY ONE THAT'S NINE AT NIGHT
AT SO AS AS THE FOLKS COME
FORWARD TO HELP OUT WITH THAT SB
SIX SIXTY NINE WILL ENTERTAIN A
VOTE ON SB SIX TWENTY ONE OUT OF
DEFERENCE TO THE AUTHOR. SIX
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP SIX TWENTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ALAN HI ALAN HI BAIT.
IL SKINNER STERN STONE. SIX
TWENTY ONE STONE I LIKE CASCADE.
I CAST AFTER THAT THAT WILL.
REMAIN OPEN OKAY SO WE'RE NOT
GONNA TURN ITEM SIXTEEN YEAR
AGENDAS MEMBERS THIS IS SB SIX
SIXTY NINE RELATING TO THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FIND ITS --
CENTER COPIER [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
SHARE AND SENATORS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL.
SIX SIX NINE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER FUND.
AND THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
TRUST.
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AS A DEN A FIGHT
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS.
ON THE HUMAN RIGHTS.
RIGHT TO WATER PORTAL THE
CHRONICALLY FAIL TO SERVICE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE SMALL RURAL SYSTEMS SERVING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES MANY
OF WHICH ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND A
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION IS LONG
OVERDUE.
A KEY PART OF SELLING THIS
CRISIS IS THE CREATION OF A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE TO
ASSIST THE STRUGGLING PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS.
PARTICULARLY FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE R. O. N. M. COSTS
WHICH GENERALLY CANNOT BE FUNDED
WITH THE EXISTING FEDERAL.
AND STATE SAFE DRINKING WATER
SOURCES.
SENATE BILL SIX SIX NINE WOULD
ADDRESS THE GAP IN FUNDING AT
THE STATE LEVEL BY CREATING THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER TRUST.
THE TRUST WOULD BE CREATED IN
THE STATE TREASURY AND BE
FINANCED WITH GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS DURING A BUDGET SURPLUS
YEAR.
THE RECORD STATE BUDGET SURPLUS
THIS YEAR MAKE MAKES IT A
PERFECT TIME TO CREATE AND FUND
THE TRUST IN THIS ACTUALLY COULD
BE FUNDED OVER AT A NUMBER OF
YEARS -- THE TRUST'S PRINCIPLES
WOULD BE INVESTED IN THE NET
INCOME WOULD BE TRANSFERRED TO A
SAFE DRINKING WATER FIND THAT
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
WOULD USE TO FIND SOLUTIONS ON
THE GROUND AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL.
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR IT -- INAM
AND FUNDING FOR CONSOLIDATIONS
REPLACEMENT WATER AND SYSTEM
ADMINISTRATION.
FINDING THE TRUST WITH GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS DURING A BUDGET
SURPLUS YEAR WOULD TAP INTO A
PROGRESSIVE SOURCE OF INCOME TAX
REVENUE.
INSTEAD OF CREATING A REGRESSIVE
DRINKING WATER TAX ON WATER
USERS THAT ADDS TO THE COST OF
WATER.
THE MOST RECENT STATE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ONLY ADDRESSES UNSAFE
WATER SYSTEMS WITH FIFTEEN OR
MORE CONNECTIONS AND DOES NOT
ADDRESS PRIVATE WELLS AND STATE
SMALL SYSTEMS.
BY FOCUSING ON WATER ON
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SB SIX
SIX NINE WOULD COMPLEMENT
EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDING SOURCES FOR CAPITAL
COSTS.
BYE FOR PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
THE NM NEEDS THAT THE STATE
PRELIMINARY PRELIMINARILY
ASSESSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THIS
MEANS.
THAT SB SIX SIX NINE IS THE
FASTEST WAY TO IMMEDIATELY
ADDRESSED THE NEEDS OF THE
LARGEST AFFECTED POPULATIONS IN
THE NEAREST TIME FRAME.
THIS IS A REASONED APPROACH TO
MANAGING THIS CRISIS NOW.
WHILE THE WATER BOARD USES THE
THREE MILLION IN FUNDING
PROVIDED TO THEM LAST YEAR BY
THIS LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE HOW
TO ASSESS THE NEEDS FOR
INDIVIDUAL WELLS AND STATE SMALL
SYSTEMS.
ILLITERATE A LINEAR LINEAR
APPROACH FIXING EACH WELL WANTED
TIME IS INEFFICIENT AND NOT
SUSTAINABLE.
SB SIX SIX NINE WOULD PROVIDE A
DURABLE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE WHILE KEEPING WATER FOR
DOUBLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
GIVE THE WATER BOARD THE ROOM TO
CONDUCT ITS DUE DILIGENCE FOR
DRESSING THE NON REGULATED SMALL
SYSTEMS AND PRIVATE WELLS.
WITH ME TODAY TO PRY TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OR CINDY TECH FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES AND DANIELLE BUT
BY A SET FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERRY ALLEN AND
MEMBERS CINDY TACK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE SUPPORT THE BILL
WERE A CO SPONSOR WITH CMU WAY.
EVERYBODY WHO'S WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE AGREES THAT THERE IS A
REAL PROBLEM THAT HAS TO BE
SOLVED.
EVERYBODY WHO'S WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE AGREES THERE NEED TO BE
NEEDS TO BE A FUNDING SOLUTIONS
THIS YEAR.
AND WE APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THAT TOPIC
WE THINK THAT THE TRUST PROPOSED
AN SP SIX SIX NINE IS A GOOD
SOLUTION.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING TO THE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUMMARY
DOCUMENT.
THERE'S A QUOTE AT PAGE ONE
TWENTY SIX THE SAYS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT REMAINING CHALLENGE
IS THE LACK OF STABLE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR LONG TERM OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS.
OF DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS.
NO THIS BILL SB SIX SIX NINE IS
NOT LIMITED TO FUNDING OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS BUT IT
WOULD ADDRESS THAT HE FUNDING
GAP.
SP SIX SIX NINE FOCUSES ON
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS THAT
CHRONICALLY VIOLATE THE FEDERAL
OR STATE DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS IN SYSTEMS THAT ARE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
REALLY NEED.
FUNDING ASSISTANCE IT WOULD
ADDRESS -- IN INCLUDE NITRATE IN
ITS SCOPE AND IT INCLUDES THE
OTHER.
CONTAMINANTS FOR WHICH THERE ARE
FEDERAL OR STATE DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR CONSOLIDATION AND
CONSOLIDATIONS AS THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
SYSTEMS THAT WOULD NEED
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
FUNDING.
SO THAT'S A POSITIVE ASPECT AS
WELL IT'S ALSO HAS FUNDING FOR
REPLACEMENT WATER AND FOR
ADMINISTRATOR OR MANAGERIAL --
CONTRACTORS.
NO THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING MECHANISM TO
PROPOSALS FOR WATER TAX RIGHT
NOW IN THE LEGISLATURE THERE'S
TWO OF THOSE ONE IS IN BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THAT LANGUAGE IS VERY SIMILAR TO
THE LANGUAGE THAT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION HAD LAST YEAR AND
THAT DID NOT PASS.
THERE'S ALSO A WATER TAX
PROPOSED IN EIGHTY TWO SEVENTEEN
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WITH
THE PROPOSAL FOR A TRUST IS A
BETTER APPROACH FOR MANY REASONS
THE Q. ONE THAT'LL MENTION FOR
THIS COMMITTEE IS THAT.
THE TRUST WOULD NOT ADD TO THE
COST OF WATER IT WOULDN'T MAKE
WATER LESS AFFORDABLE IN
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT OF COURSE SENATOR
CAFIERO MENTIONED THAT.
ON WITH THE RECENT -- IN RECORD
BUDGET SURPLUS THIS YEAR WE
THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN FUND THE TRUST
WITH A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THAT
BUDGET SURPLUS.
SO WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
MOVE THE BILL IT'S A GOOD
SOLUTION WE ARE TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
NOW NO MORE BIRTHDAY BASH.
YEAH.
ALTHOUGH I GOT A TIARA BIRTHDAY
WEEK BUT THE BIRTHDAY WEEK NO I
I WOULD LOVE A BIRTHDAY MONTH
THAT OKAY ALL RIGHT THERE YOU GO
OKAY.
BUT I DID HAVE A VERY NICE
BIRTHDAY THANK YOU HEARD OF MY
NAME IS DANIEL BLASTED WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD OF
BECAUSE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS
OF SB -- SIX SIX NINE AS
OUTLINED BY THE AUTHOR AND OUR
CO SPONSOR WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
NEEDS TO BE SOLVED -- THE
SENATOR IN OUR COSPONSORED DID A
GREAT JOB EXPLAINING THE TRUST
SO I AM GOING TO FOCUS A LITTLE
BIT ON THE CONCERNS FROM THE
OPPOSITION WE ASK THE SERGEANT
TO DISTRIBUTED DOCUMENT TO ALL
OF YOU TODAY.
IT OUTLINES THOSE -- CONCERNS
AND OUR RESPONSES IN DETAIL BUT
I'M GONNA FOCUS ON JUST A COUPLE
TODAY -- THERE'S A CONCERN THAT
THE PRESS DOESN'T PROVIDE ENOUGH
FUNDING BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
FIRST ADDRESS THE EXISTING
ESTIMATES TO TRY AND TACKLE THE
FUNDING NEEDED -- THESE
ESTIMATES VARY WIDELY BETWEEN
FORTY THREE AND A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
FORTY THREE MILLION WAS
DEVELOPED THROUGH A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
AND AS FOR AN M. COST -- WHICH
AS WAS NOTED IS THE MAJOR
FUNDING GAP THE HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION ACTUALLY INCLUDES
ONAM COSTS AND AND CAPITAL COSTS
FOR WHICH THERE IS ALREADY
FINDING.
AND WAS GENERATED BY A THIRD
PARTY -- CONSULTANT AND IN THE
CONSULTANTS ESTIMATE THERE WAS
AN ADMISSION THAT THERE'S NO
STATEWIDE STUDY YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE DATA QUANTIFY THE
COST.
AND IN ADDITION THE STATE WATER
BOARD SAID IN THEIR TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SAFE DRINKING WATER PLAN.
THE COSTS OF REQUIRING PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS SERVING LESS THAN
TEN THOUSAND SERVICE CONNECTIONS
TO ME PRIMARY DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS CANNOT BE ACCURATELY
ESTIMATED GIVEN THE VARIABLES
INVOLVED IN SUCH AN ESTIMATE.
AS NOTED IN NEED NEEDS
ASSESSMENT BY THE BOARD IS UNDER
WAY BUT AS YOU CAN SEE THE TOTAL
NEED IS NOT FROM YOU FOR ME IT
FIRMLY BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AS ENVISIONED THE TRUST WOULD
GENERATE MORE THAN THE AMOUNT
ESTIMATED BY THE STATE BOARD AND
IF MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED IN THE
FUTURE IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
PRECLUDE THE LEGISLATURE FROM
ADDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO THE
TRUST TO GENERATE THAT AMOUNT.
AND LASTLY THERE'S ALSO CONCERNS
THAT THE TRUST IS LIMITED IN THE
UNIVERSE OF SYSTEMS THAT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING -- I
THINK THAT AS SENATOR CAFIERO
INTERPOSE SPONSOR OUTLINES I'M
OUR POSITION ON THAT BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THE NEW ASSESSMENT IS
EXPECTED TO EXPLORE WAYS TO
ASSESS AND ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
PRIVATE WELLS AND STATE SMALL
SYSTEMS.
INCLUDING CONSOLIDATION WHICH WE
BELIEVE -- WOULD BE THE SOLUTION
FOR MANY OF THESE AREAS AND
WOULD REDUCE THE OVERALL NEED.
AND WE BELIEVE THE TRUST -- IS A
BETTER APPROACH FOR SOLVING THIS
ISSUE IT DOES NOT RELY ON A
REGRESSIVE TAX ON WATER.
AND I WOULD PROVIDE THE FUNDING
NEEDED FOR SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BY
BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE
BOARD IS NEEDING ASSISTANCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER FOLKS WANNA WIN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE --
GREG'S LAWMAKERS ARE OUR WATER
RATE PAYERS MONEY HARD AT WORK
HERE.
AT GREG'S LONIGAN THE SAN JUAN
WATER DISTRICT -- REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
MORNING I'M BROOK JONES AND
PRESIDENT OF THE R. LINDA WATER
DISTRICT.
AND I HAVE A FEW THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT THIS BILL WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
ACCESS TO SAFE CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND RESIDENTS.
WE THEREFORE SUPPORT SB.
SIX SIXTY NINE WE THINK THAT'S
B. SIX SIXTY NINE IS PREFERABLE
TO THE APPROACHES DESCRIBED THE
GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL IN A B..
TWO SEVENTEEN WHICH INVOLVES.
A WATER TAX. FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS.
I THINK IT'S BAD POLICY. TO HAVE
A WATER TAX.
TAX WATER IS ESSENTIAL TO LIFE.
IT SHOULD BE TAX FREE TAXING
WATER IS REGRESSIVE.
HARDER ON THE POOR WE JUST THINK
WATER SHOWS UP FOR FREE NICE AND
CLEAN NO ONE PAYS FOR IT.
YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR THE DELIVERY
I BET SOMEONE PAIN FOR ERIC
COMES FROM HEAVEN IT'S YOURS
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
FAXING WATER IS INEFFICIENT.
IMPOSING A NEW BUREAUCRACY OF
TAX COLLECTORS WITHIN CITIZENS.
CITIES IN WATER DISTRICTS AND IT
MAKES THE WATER MORE EXPENSIVE.
TAXING WATERS DIFFICULT
PRECEDENT UNDO.
AND TAXES WILL LIKELY BECOME
MORE ONEROUS AS TIME GOES ON
TAXING WATER BUILD FUNDS
RESERVES TAKE TIME.
WELL THE NEED FOR SOLUTIONS IS
URGENT.
THE OTHER HAND SB SIX SIXTY NINE
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGES.
IT IMMEDIATELY FINDS A SAFE
DRINKING WATER TRUST FUND BY
PROVIDING STATE BUDGET SURPLUS
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
ENABLING QUICK ACTION.
IT ALSO PROVIDE WE'RE GONNA ASK
IT IS A WEEK WE'VE HEARD FROM
TWO I'M I'M I'M NOT I'M SORRY TO
BE BEHIND ME.
YEAH OKAY.
FINALLY WHEN MATED WITH SP.
FOUR ONE FOUR IT PROVIDES A
PERMANENT FIX.
MAKING PEOPLE SELF SUFFICIENT
ALL THE DISTRICTS SELF
SUFFICIENT.
AND WE'D STRONGLY SUPPORT BOTH
SIX SIXTY NINE AND FOUR FOURTEEN
I SENT A COUPLE YEAH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR IMAGE.
I I FEEL ARE NOT TAKING TIME
HERE TODAY FOR EAST VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT AND ALSO YOU A WATER
AGENCY AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE AUTHOR'S INTELLIGENCE
INNOVATIVE AND WATER TAX
AVOIDING APPROACH. ONE TURN
MEMBERS THEIR DOLPHIN BAVLI
CALIFORNIA CITIES SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU.
LARGER MEMO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTRY COSTA WATER DISTRICT IN
FORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'VE OU
BETTER BRUSH WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO CHRISTY PHLEGM BEHALF OF
THREE VALLEYS MUNICIPAL.
REINER JACKIE WITH THE REGIONAL
WATER AUTHORITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
NO AUTOMATIC WITH THE CITY OF
ROSE FELL INTO PARK BRISCOE.
ROSA ROSA.
WAS LIKE BRISCO.
OKAY KATHY VIA TELEPHONE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT OKAY.
GET THE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT AND GIVE A
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS MELANIE GRIFFITH WITH
CANTON AUTUMN HARTMAN ON BEHALF
OF IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JASON I COULD WITH THAT'LL STEAM
GILBERT ROBES AND SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHASING AND
SAW THIS ON BEHALF OF ST GABLE
VALLEY WATER ASSOCIATION LIKE
WOOD AND THE CITY ROSALYN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DR RIGHT LA COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION ALSO KNOWN AS BIZ FED
AND SUPPORT WITHIN ONE QUICK
COMMENT -- AT HEALTH THAT SIMPLY
HEALTH CARE COMMITTEE YESTERDAY
A LOT OF THE CONVERSATIONAL
SUGAR TAXES ALSO REVOLVED AROUND
AFFORDABLE WATER.
PRACTICAL SOLUTION BACK TO
CENTER.
GOOD MORNING I LAURIE JOHNSON ON
BEHALF OF THE MONTEREY PENINSULA
WATER MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN THE
CITY OF WATSONVILLE AND SUPPORT.
RAQUEL I YELL OUT ON BEHALF OF
THIS -- WATER AGENCY ALTERADO
YOUR RECREATION DISTRICT ROLLING
WATER DISTRICT AND WHILE NOT
FALLING WATER DISTRICT.
IN SUPPORT.
JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GREG UNDER
CENTER REPRESENTS SACRAMENTO
SUBURBAN WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THESE ARE TWO GUYS WITH THE
WATERPROOF -- VARIOUS CLIENTS AS
SUPPORT I AM A WATER AGENCY CITY
OF FRESNO.
COUNTY WATER USE THE LONG BEACH
FOR DEPARTMENT AND BY D. N.
SAMBAR DEER VALLEY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THURSDAY WERE SOME HAVE THE
MISSILE WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE
COUNTY IN SPORT.
GOOD MORNING CURE ROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BATH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CUCAMONGA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MORNING JR MEMBERS SAID MANNING
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ADAM ROBIN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
IT'S PART.
JANA SAID TODAY -- FOR TIDEWATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING HIGHLANDER LAWSUIT THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATIONS.
FOR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORNING
DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON YOUR
BEARD BY THE WAY.
VERY COOL [inaudible]
VERY COOL.
THE THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER
EVERY DAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
PROBABLY BECAUSE WE PUT A TAX ON
RAZOR BLADES OR SOMETHING RIGHT
SO.
HE SAYS.
ACTING TO THAT OKAY SO -- AND
SAY LET'S NOW I HAVE AN EMPTY
FOR THE OPPOSITION TO COME UP
AND RAISE THEIR CONCERNS.
MAY RECEIVE ALREADY.
GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JONATHAN NELSON
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER'S. FOR
OVER TEN YEARS NOW WE HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR THE MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
SAFE WATER.
POISONED BY EVERYTHING FROM LEAD
IN URBAN AREAS TO NITRATES
ARSENIC IN RURAL AREAS.
EVEN THOUGH WE OPPOSE SB SIX SIX
NINE AND HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE INTEREST BEHIND THIS
PROPOSAL.
WE ARE DEEPLY RESPECTFUL OF THE
SENATOR AND WE ARE RESPECTFUL OF
THE CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE
HAVING TODAY AND IT WILL
CONTINUE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
SO WE COME HERE TODAY WITH JUST
ONE SIMPLE REQUEST TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO THE SENATE.
PLEASE PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND MAKE SURE WE LEAVE NO ONE
OUT OF A SOLUTION AS WE ACT THIS
YEAR.
YOU SEE THE VERY PREMISE OF THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUN CAMPAIGN.
REFLECTED IN PROPOSALS BY THE
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION SUMMIT
MEMBER AND WATER GARCIA AND
SENATOR MINING.
IS THAT WE ARE ONE STATE.
AND THAT BY JOINING HANDS
TOGETHER WE CAN MAKE SURE EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO SAFE
WATER.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
WILL STAND FIRM.
AGAINST ANY PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
LEAVE OUT ENTIRE SEGMENTS OF THE
POPULATION.
AS SB SIX SIX NINE WOULD DO.
BY LIMITING ASSISTANCE TO WATER
SYSTEMS OF A CERTAIN TYPE AND
SIZE.
YOU WOULD EXCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED SCHOOLS AND
AN ESTIMATED TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL ALSO MERELY PROVIDES A
PROMISE OF ASSISTANCE IT WOULD
NOT ACTUALLY PROVIDE RELIEF
UNLESS AND UNTIL WE SECURED A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
OF GENERAL FUND FUNDING.
WHICH BOTH WE IN THE ALLEY --
ESTIMATE WOULD BE OVER FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
IT WOULD BE BOTH THE GREATEST
IRONY AND A GRAVE INJUSTICE AT
THE VERY COMMUNITIES THAT
STARTED THIS EFFORT WERE THE
ONES DENIED SAFE WATER AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
WE ARE TIRED OF LIVING A SECOND
CLASS CITIZENS WITH SECOND CLASS
WATER.
WE MUST NOT TO OUR ACTIONS TODAY
AND IN THE COMING WEEKS
PERPETUATE THAT INJUSTICE ANY
LONGER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND HAPPY THE
LOTUS WORK THAT DAY.
MY NAME IS CAMILLA TRAVIS I AM
THE DAUGHTER OF THE LOTUS WORK
THEN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE THE LOTUS WORTH THE
FOUNDATION AND MET A MOTHER OF
TWO SMALL CHILDREN.
I AM HERE TO EXPRESS MY GRAVE
CONCERN ABOUT SB SIX SIX NINE I
AM HERE IN SOLIDARITY WITH EVERY
CALIFORNIAN THAT LACKS ACCESS TO
SAFE.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER I LIVE IN
RURAL KERN COUNTY AND HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE LACK OF CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FIRSTHAND.
I LIVE IN THE TINY
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY OF KEEN
THE HOME OF THE NATIONAL CHAVIS
CENTER MY NEIGHBORS AND I PAY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
WATER THAT IS CHECKED IN FROM
TEN MILES AWAY FROM THE TO
HATCHET BE WATER BASIN.
IT'S BEEN STORED AND A LARGE
TANK AND PUMPED UP TO OUR HOME
WE CANNOT DRINK OR COOK WITH
THIS WATER THE WATER SYSTEM IS
OWNED AND OPERATED BY THE UNION
PACIFIC RAILROAD WHO HAS
NEGLECTED TO PROPERLY MAINTAIN
OUR WATER SYSTEM.
AROUND NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
UNION PACIFIC REMOVED A TEN MILE
WATER LINE FROM TO HATCH SHOULD
BE TOO KEEN AND REPLACED IT WITH
A MALFUNCTIONING WELL.
SYSTEM THAT WENT DRY OVER TEN
YEARS AGO SINCE THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THE RAILROAD WANTED TO
ABANDON THE COMMUNITY BUT WE
SUED BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND WON OUR FIGHT TO REQUIRE
UNION PACIFIC TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
LAST SUMMER THE PUMP BROKE AND
WE WERE WITHOUT WATER FOR OVER A
WEEK BEFORE THE PROBLEM WAS
IDENTIFIED AND RESOLVED.
SOME KEEN RESIDENTS HAVE WELLS
AND WILL NOT BENEFIT FROM S. B.
SIX SIX NINE CALIFORNIANS
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IS UNFAIR.
AN EQUAL AND UNDRESSED YES THIS
DOES NOT LOOK LIKE EXCLUDING THE
MOST VULNERABLE AROUND US FROM
HAVING SAFE WATER.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE SUPPORTED
GOVERNOR NEWSOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT AUTO GARCIA AND SENATOR
MINING BY ADVOCATING FOR THE
PASSAGE OF THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUN
WHICH WILL HELP EVERYONE. FOR
THOSE THAT SAY WE CANNOT PASS
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUN AND INCLUDE ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH A C. SEP
WHETHER.
IT CAN BE DONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHER FOLKS
WANNA RAISE CONCERNS ARE VOICED
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU -- JIM WINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA --
WERE VERY SKEPTICAL ABOUT --
GENERAL FUND FORMULAS THAT ONLY
PROVIDE FUNDING -- IN SURPLUS
YEARS WEKNOW THAT MINERAL FUN
REVENUES ARE VERY VOLATILE --
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE AND
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS PROBLEM WE
REALLY THINK THAT WE NEED A
DEDICATED AN ONGOING SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCE.
THANK YOU. THREE THE BREAKFAST
ON BEHALF OF SERIES THREE'S IS A
GROUP OF LARGE BUSINESSES WORKED
WORKING TOWARDS SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS PRACTICES IN OPPOSITION.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT
AMONG CALIFORNIAN.
OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING PUBLIC GARCIA WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
OPPOSITION WE SUPPORT -- WE
APPRECIATE THE CONSTRUCTIVE
THINKING BUT DON'T.
BELIEVE THERE'S A SUBSTITUTE FOR
DEDICATED FUNDING.
THANK.
THESE ARE WHAT.
W. FUNDING [inaudible]
SUBSTITUTE OKAY.
MORNING MICHAEL CLAIBORNE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY -- IN
OPPOSITION WE WORK WITH THE
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES YOU STRUGGLE WITH
WATER KEPT A QUALITY
CONTAMINATION.
I AND MANY OF THOSE RESIDENTS
RELY ON PRIVATE WELLS.
THAT ARE CONTAMINATED. FOR
EXAMPLE -- RAMON NEAR DELL HI HO
VITA IN TOMBSTONE TERRITORY TORY
IN FRESNO COUNTY -- THOSE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE RELIANT ON
PRIVATE WELLS AND WE'RE WORKING
TO EXTEND OUT PUBLIC DRINKING
WATER SERVICE TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES -- THIS SOLUTION
WOULDN'T ACTUALLY FUN THOSE
SOLUTIONS -- WILL CONTINUE
WORKING ON THOSE PROJECTS AND
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION
THAT DOESN'T LEAVE COMMUNITIES
BEHIND.
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY GET THEIR
DRINKING WATER -- AND WE THINK
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT THIS YEAR -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
A CAFE NANDO'S DOMESTIC PRIOR
WELL OWNER WITHIN SAVE WATER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANKS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOSEPHINE YET TO COME FROM A
SMALL COMMUNITY AND FOR REAL --
A MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE I
BELIEVE PRIVATE WALLET OWNER
SURE ALSO HAVE SAFE DRINKING
WATER THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ROSIE
HERNANDEZ AND I'M FROM WEST
GOSHEN I'M HERE REPRESENTING
I'VE -- I WHAT COLLISION AND
ALSO REPRESENT AN OP OVER THIRTY
HOMES IN MY COMMUNITY THAT WERE
LEFT BEHIND WITH WHEN WE
CONNECTED TO THE CITY AND THEY
DO SEARCHES BUT HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND ALL THE OTHER NUMBER IS THE
ONE ON THE LINE YEAH.
THE LEARNER POSSIBLY BY THE IF
THEN CONSIDER THIS TO BE THE
FIFTH.
SASHA HER NAME WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY --
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JULIE AT
CHRISTIAN SMITH I'M WITH THE
WATER FOUNDATION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH MANY
OF THE COMMUNITIES HERE FOR MANY
YEARS.
AND AS I'M SURE MANY OF YOU KNOW
THIS IS NOT A REAL SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEM IT'S ONLY A PARTIAL
PEACE OF THE PICTURE AND SO WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION.
JENNIFER CLARY ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION AN AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION --
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THERE'S
FORTY SEVEN SCHOOLS ON THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER LISTED CURRENTLY
DON'T HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER
THEY'RE NOT THEY WOULDN'T BE
HELPED BY THIS BILL.
MONTEREY COUNTY OVERSEAS NINE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY WATER
SYSTEMS WITH FEWER THAN FIFTEEN
CONNECTIONS THEY WOULD NOT BE
HELPED BY THIS BILL SO WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE A COMPLETE SOLUTION
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DID YOU.
VVC LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
REGISTERING OPPOSITION FOR
POLICY LINK SEE EARLY FOUNDATION --
AND AND SELF HELP ENTERPRISES AS
A ALONG WITH THE COMMUNITY GROUP
COMMUNITY UNITED IN ONE HOUR.
MATTHEW BIGGER PLANNING
CONSERVATION THE PCO DOES
APPRECIATE THE NEED HERE AND THE
INTENT -- BUT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES THE APPROACH.
THANK YOU OKAY.
I SAW THE ITEM IS NOW BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
THOUGHTS -- A CINEMA CASKEY.
THE LECTURE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCLUDED ON THIS BILL -- WE
DON'T HAVE JURISDICTION WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD I'M.
AS I UNDERSTAND WHAT COULD CUT
THIS ONCE WHEN WE ASK ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE IN ONE ONE ONE OF YOU
TO COME AND ONE OF YOU.
TO SO WE HAVE A BALANCE.
THE QUESTION.
FOR AGAIN IT'S A NICE LECTURE
ABOUT THE MILLION PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER
BUT THERE'S ONLY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT ARE UNDER
THE JURISDICTION THE STATE WATER
RESOURCE BOARD WHICH WE HAVE
JURISDICTION TO DO SOMETHING.
IS THAT CORRECT.
THE AUTHOR.
IN THE MORNING TILL IN EVERY
BILL THAT'S COME BEFORE US ARE
BILLS THAT ARE TAILORED FOR
AREAS THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS JURISDICTION OVER
RIGHT IS THAT CORRECT.
WELL I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE MINING
BILL.
IT'S NOT FAIR BUT RIGHT NOW BUT
IT IS WITH THE SAME UNIVERSE.
PART OF WHAT I'M GETTING AT IS
PART OF THE OBJECTION HERE IS
THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE WELLS THAT
ARE NOT THAT ARE NON POSSIBLE
WATER.
THEY WANT THIS BILL TO FIX IT
AND PEOPLE WOULD HAVE SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE 14% OR FOURTEEN HOOK
UPS THAT ARE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF STATE WATER
RESOURCE BOARD WHAT YOUR BILL
THE FIX IT.
AND PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVE WATER
SYSTEM ONE RUN BY A RAILROAD
VERSUS THE STATE WATER RESEARCH
ESTATE COMMUNITY BOARD WHAT YOUR
BILL FIX IT AND MY UNDERSTANDING
PLEASE CORRECT ME IS THAT WE%
DON'T HAVE JURISDICTION. TO DO
THAT.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AS WELL
SO SO THAT'S A DIFFERENT
SOLUTION THAT'S A DIFFERENT
THAT'S A PROBLEM BUT I'D SAY
THAT'S THAT'S IT WE'RE BEING
URGED TO OPPOSE THIS FOR IT ONLY
FIX IS HALF OF THE PROBLEM.
AND WE HAVE A VARIETY OF BILLS
ON CONSOLIDATION INCLUDING EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT'S A WATER
DISTRICT HAS NO REASON
WHATSOEVER WHATSOEVER SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
HAVING A OF WATER DISTRICT THAT
DOESN'T JOIN AN ADJOINING WATER
DISTRICT AND YOU'VE DONE
LEGISLATION AND I'VE DONE
LEGISLATION AND THEY'LL BE MORE
LEGISLATION FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
TO CONSOLIDATE AND JOIN BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO DO.
I HAVE OTHER REASONS TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL BUT BUT THE BUT BUT
THE REASONS FOR BEING PRO PROPER
HERE BY OPPOSITION HAVE
SOMETHING O DO WITH ENTIRELY.
DIFFERENT PROBLEM WORSE THAT
WERE SOLD WE'RE TOLD THAT WE
SHOULDN'T FIX HALF THE PROBLEM
UNLESS WE FIX ALL THE PROBLEMS
AND THAT'S NOT IN THERE ARE
JURISDICTIONS THERE'S FIFTY A
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
GO GET HIM GO ASK THE QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
MAR A OTHER QUESTION IS ON THE
CORPUS OF THE STRESS.
THE ONE POINT.
THREE OUT OF GIVE YOU THE THE
THE THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S PRODUCED WITH THAT -- AND
I UNDERSTAND WE CAN ALWAYS COME
BACK AND ADD TO THE CORPUS I I I
GET THAT.
I DON'T SEE ANY PRIORITY THAT'S
PUT HERE ON THAT HOW THAT WOULD
BE [inaudible]
DIVVIED UP.
IS THERE ANY INTENTION HERE OR
IS THIS SORT OF FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE WHO'S WHO NEEDS -- NM YEAH
THE DATA.
WE HAD.
A LITTLE BIT DOWN THE LINE NICE
I REALIZE.
THIS BILL PROPOSES THAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD WOULD HAVE A
PROCESS WITH AN IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN INCLUDING STAKEHOLDER INPUT
INTO THAT.
SO IT DOESN'T SAY ABSOLUTELY
THIS CATEGORY HAS TO GO FIRST TO
HAVE THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY ON IT.
AND THE THE KEY IS THE PUBLIC
PROCESS AT THE STATE WATER BOARD
IN THAT PLAN AND CONCEIVABLY THE
WATER RESOURCE BOARD WHO IS
CHARGED WITH.
HELPING CONSOLIDATE UNDER
PERFORMING AND NON PERFORMING
DISTRICTS COULD USE THIS AS A
CARROT FOR EITHER AN ASSOCIATION
OF THREE UNDER PRFORMING
DISTRICTS TO COME TOGETHER TO
TRY.
TO GET IT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
NOT THAT JOINS WITH ANOTHER
PERFORMING DISTRICT THAT GETS
THE O. N. M. THAT THEY NEED TO
GET IT UP IS THAT YOUR THINKING
MADAM.
AUTHOR IT IS MY THINKING AND NOT
ONLY THAT THE STATE WATER BOARD
IS GOING TO BE IN CHARGE OF THE
BOND FUNDS THAT PROVIDE.
RESOURCES FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
OR THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
THE PROJECTS AND SO THIS IS THE
O. N. M. IT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO TO GET THAT GOING BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TAKES
CARE PRESUMABLY IF EVER.
IF WE GET MANAGEMENT IN THERE
THAT KNOWS HOW THIS WORKS.%
UP TO SNUFF THE NECK WOULD BE
IMPROVED.
I HAVE STILL SOME CONCERNS HERE
BUT I'M VERY.
I GUESS SOME OF YOUR CHARGE
YOU'RE IN CHARGE I'M I'M GOOD.
I'M GOOD AT IT I I I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL WILL BE PROCEEDING
THERE'S THIS DEBATE IS NOT THE
LAST ONE THAT WE HAVE ON MAY I
HAVE THE OPPOSITE THAT
OPPORTUNITY RESPONDED AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
SOME OF THE POINTS RAISED
[inaudible]
HAPPY.
I ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION OR MAKE
COMMENTS.
AND THEY DON'T ALL IS THERE A
MOTION [inaudible] FOR US.
THE MOVE BY SENATOR STONE ON
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HELLO I'M SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE SENATOR KERR YEAH
ACTUALLY ASKED FOR AND I THINK
YOU.
THE ITEM NUMBER SIX SP SIX SIX
NINE THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE.
ALAN.
WAIT.
BAIT HI HILL.
IL I SKINNER.
SKINNER ICE STERN STERN I STONE.
STONE I I KELSEY.
MY CAL SKINNER [inaudible]
WITH A THAT'S FIVE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN.
BECAUSE OF WHERE WE ARE
[inaudible]
BILL
FORTY YEAH [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ARE YOU [inaudible]
RULER LET'S [inaudible]
RATHER THAN [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS IS ITEM MINE NUMBER TWO AND
ARE SENT TO SKINNER.
THANKS SO MUCH -- ITEM NUMBER
FIVE I'M NOT IN THE RIGHT
POSITION IT'S S. P. FORTY FOUR
CORRECT YEAH THREE FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU WONDERFUL THANK YOU --
VICE CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN WITH I WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THEN WHY DID I INTRODUCE SP.
FORTY FOUR SEVEN OUT OF THE CAN
CITIES IN THE US WITH THE MOST
POLLUTED AIR STILL TODAY.
ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
FOSSIL FUEL POWERED.
FOSSIL FUEL DIESEL POWERED
TRUCKS AND BUSES ARE SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE.
OF THAT POLLUTION.
JAZZ THAT CATEGORY OF VEHICLES
ALONE.
ARE RESPONSIBLE 433%.
OF THE SMOG CAUSING POLLUTION
SERVE THE EMISSIONS THAT CREATE
THE SMOG.
AND 25% OF OUR TOTAL GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION WHICH IS THE
LARGEST SINGLE SOURCE OF
EMISSIONS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER IS
PARTICULARLY [inaudible]
HARMFUL.
TO LONGS TO CHILDREN AND THERE'S
A LINK.
BETWEEN DIESEL EXHAUST IN CANCER
AND HEART DISEASE.
INTERESTINGLY A RESEARCH REPORT
OUT OF EUROPE.
FOUND THAT MORE PEOPLE IN EUROPE
DIE EARLY.
PRIME DIESEL CARS BAD AIR
QUALITY THAN FROM CIGARETTES.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE IN THAT
SITUATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT S. B. FORTY FOUR DOES IS
DIRECT OUR AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
TO HELP.
DEVELOP A PLAN FOR HOW ARE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
SECTOR THOSE VEHICLES THAT MOST
RELY ON PETROLEUM BASED DIESEL.
CAN HELP MEET OUR CLEAN AIR AND
ARE.
CARBON REDUCTION GOALS AND NOW I
WILL ALLOW MY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT TO SPEAK [inaudible]
THE CENTER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M RUNNING
SHORT ON BEHALF OF CAL START
WERE -- TECHNOLOGY CONSORTIUM
THAT'S BEEN WORKING FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS TO ACCELERATE THE
COMMERCIALIZATION.
AD GROWTH OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY.
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS HAVE GIVEN RISE TO A
RENAISSANCE IN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING IN THIS STATE.
SHOP HERE TO RESEARCH DESIGN
BUILD CLEAN VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES.
ACROSS ALL VEHICLE CLASSES
COMPANIES LIKE FOR TERRA MOTIVE
B. Y. DE TESLA CHANGE.
GREEN POWER TRANSPARENT.
ARE JUST A FEW THE MANUFACTURERS
THAT HAVE COME HERE TO THIS
STATE AND ARE GROWING OUT
BECAUSE OF CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS.
THESE COMPANIES ARE JUST THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG OF WHAT COULD BE
TO COME.
AS A RESULT MANY NEW VEHICLE
CLASSES IN THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE SPACE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING OR HAVE
ALREADY BECOME COMMERCIALIZED.
AS LONG AS IT STAYS STAYS THE
COURSE WITH THIS CLINIC IN
MINUTES THESE TRENDS WILL NOT
ONLY CONTINUE BUT INCREASE.
SB FORTY FOUR IS THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP IN OUR STATE
PLANNING EFFORTS TO KEEP
RATIONING DOWN VEHICLE EMISSIONS
AND SIGNALING TO MANUFACTURERS
THAT WE ARE NOT BACKING DOWN
FROM OUR COMMITMENTS.
PARALLEL TO THIS STATE IN THAT
IT INVESTMENT INCENTIVE FUNDING
FROM CAP AND TRADE IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING THE
COMMERCIALIZATION PROCESS TO
CREATE THE INDUCEMENTS NEEDED
FOR COMPANIES TO KEEP BUILDING A
PIPELINE OF ADVANCE CLEAN TRUCK.
BUS AND OFFERED EQUIPMENT. TO
MAKE A PROGRAM FOR BUILDING NEW
IN MAY MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY SUCCESSFUL
THERE NEEDS TO BE PROGRAM
CERTAINTY SEVERAL YEARS AHEAD.
THAT IS BECAUSE IT TAKES
MANUFACTURES OF OF TRUCKS AND
BUSES FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS TO
BRING IN NEW PRODUCT TO MARKET.
AND THOSE MANUFACTURERS ARE
UNLIKELY TO START THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING A NEW VEHICLE UNLESS
THEY CAN LOOK OUT AND HAVE A
CLEAR PICTURE OF THE DEMAND AND
THE PARTNERSHIPS AVAILABLE OVER
THAT WHOLE TIME FRAME.
ALSO FLEET OPERATORS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SCHEDULE BOTH LONG THE
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS MULTIPLE YEARS IN
ADVANCE AND UNLESS THEY HAVE A
CLEAR PICTURE OF THE RESOURCES
AND REQUIREMENTS AVAILABLE
MULTIPLE YEARS OUT.
THEY'LL HAVE A HARD TIME MAKING
INVESTMENTS BEYOND ISOLATED
EXPERIMENTS.
BUSINESSES ARE MAKING INVESTMENT
DECISIONS ON A LONG TERM BASIS
AND THE STATE NEEDS TO MORE
CLOSELY SEE SYNCHRONIZE ITS
APPROPRIATIONS AND PROGRAMS WITH
THESE INVESTMENT CYCLES.
AND DOING SO WOULD HELP TO BRING
THE MARKET. TO MORE OF THESE
VEHICLES THE MARKET FASTER AND
CONTINUE TO DRAW MORE
MANUFACTURERS IN INVESTMENTS TO
THE STATE FOR THESE REASONS WE
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I'VE A
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M WILL BEAR WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA.
EMISSIONS FROM THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS SECTOR
ADD SIGNIFICANTLY TO LOCAL AND
REGIONAL POLLUTION AND PUBLIC
HEALTH BURDENS INCLUDING
CARDIOVASCULAR AND RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS.
CANCERS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN HEALTH IMPACTS OF
PREMATURE DEATHS.
THESE BURNS ARE NOT EQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED AS MANY COMMUNITIES
FACE DISPROPORTIONATE BURDENS AN
ELEVATED CANCER RISKS DUE TO
NEARBY DIESEL HOT SPOTS LIKE OUR
PORTS IN WAREHOUSES.
THOROUGHLY WORKERS FACE HGHER
HEALTH RISK DUE TO GREATER
OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURES TO DIESEL
EXHAUST.
DIESEL EXHAUST IS CLASSIFIED AS
A TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
IT IS CLASSIFIED AS A HUMAN
CARCINOGEN BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION'S INTERNATIONAL
AGENCY FOR RESEARCH ON CANCER.
DIESEL EMISSION ENGINE EMISSIONS
ARE BELIEVED TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ABOUT 70% OF CALIFORNIANS
ESTIMATED KNOWN CANCEROUS
CONTRIBUTED BOLTED TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS.
THE OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE SHOWS
A PARTICLE POLLUTION LIKE THAT
COMING FROM DIESEL ENGINES.
CAN INCREASE THE RISK OF HEART
DISEASE LUNG CANCER ASTHMA
ATTACKS THE GREATER USE OF
ASTHMA MEDICATIONS AND CAN
INTERFERE WITH THE LUNG FUNCTION
AND DEVELOPMENT IN CHILDREN.
PARTICLE POLLUTION AND KNOCKS
EMISSIONS FROM DIESEL TRUCKS CAN
IMPACT ANYONE'S HEALTH BUT OUR
CHILDREN THE ELDERLY PEOPLE WITH
ASTHMA HEART DISEASE AND OTHER
CHRONIC ILLNESSES.
ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
THEIR FAX.
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
ARE ALSO A MAJOR SOURCE OF
CLIMATE POLLUTION THAT THREATENS%
PUBLIC HEALTH TODAY.
AND FOR GENERATIONS COMING
FORWARD FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL FORTY FOUR AND THANK THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
FOR THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATTHEW MONSON WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND ALSO --
PROGRAM THE REGIONAL ASTHMA
MANAGEMENT PREVENTION PROGRAM
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ROCKY RUSSIAN WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
US BEFORE THE FOUR AND A ME TOO
AS WELL FOR FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THREE SEPARATE VERGE ON BEHALF
OF CERES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NOT HER MOM OWNED THE BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION SUPPORT.
THE MORNING TIM CARMICHAEL AND
THEY HAVE A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY AND SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING RANK ANY CLEAN
ENERGY WE'RE THE NATION'S
LARGEST PROVIDER OF RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS TRANSPORTATION --
FUEL ACCORDING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THE VOICE CUT OFF WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHARLIE MEMBERS RHYME
FOR ANY WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
AND WELL WRITTEN ANALYSIS WITH
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN WE'RE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M SURE MEMBERS ENTRANCE WE
WITH THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION ARC -- TRADE GROUP
OFFERS LENNOX ENGINES TODAY AND
WE'RE WORKING ON A RENEWABLE A
SOURCE OF A PROPANE POWERED
VEHICLES AND WHAT.
WE THINK A COMMAND THE OFFER FOR
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBER JOSIAH
YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE BIO
ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES COALITION.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CHAMBERS BANNING RC
ON BEHALF OF SEE ON OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NINA COULD POUR A
COALITION FOR ANY OF OUR NATURAL
GAS WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MEMBERS IN EVERY
SECTOR OF THE R. G. INDUSTRY
INCLUDING ORGANIZED LABOR
UTILITIES AND PRODUCERS OF OVER
90%.
OF THE R. G. IN NORTH AMERICA
INSTRUCTS FOR IT THANK YOU.
JOHN **** FOR THREE IFTY
SILICON VALLEY AND THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA WHICH INCLUDES THREE
FIFTY SAN FRANCISCO NAPA.%
SONOMA MORAN AND THE EAST BAY
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS THE
CENTER SKINNER.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS VINCENT
WHAT MARGIN WITH LETTERMAN GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE LIGHTING MOTORS
ONE OF THOSE CALIFORNIA BASED
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS THAT
FRIENDS MENTIONED IN SPORT.
EMILY FEE REELING WITH%
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIAN UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT.
THIRTY WELLS WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIOFUELS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS TOM FOLKS I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE DIESEL
TECHNOLOGY FORUM -- WE ARE
UNABLE TO TAKE A POSITION YEA OR
NAY ON THE BILL OUR BY LAWS
PROHIBIT THAT BUT I DID WANT TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF CONCERNS.
THAT WE HAVE THE D. D. DTF IS
MADE UP OF ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
AUTOMAKERS DRUG MAKERS
COMPONENTS.
OF I'M GOING TO ASK IF YOU WOULD
COME UP AFTER WE DO THE
OPPOSITION AND THEN YOU'RE KIND
OF A TWEENER.
I'M TOTALLY BETWEEN HER AND I
FIGURED WELL.
THIS MIGHT BE A GOOD BOY CAN GET
YOU'LL HAVE A WAIT TIME BUT WELL
LET'S HAVE THE OPPOSITION COME
TO THE DESK OKAY THING THEY CAN
PRESENT THEIR MAJOR --
OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MORNING MEMBERS -- MAYBE AT THE
REFORM OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE FIRST LET ME STATE
THE CAL CHAMBER DOES NOT OBJECT
TO THE INCLUSION OF TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL INCENTIVE FUNDING TO
DEVELOP CLEAN DIESEL TECHNOLOGY.
CUSTOMER DOES OPPOSE SB FORTY
FOUR BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNIFICANT
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING IMPLEMENTED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND BECAUSE IT CREATES A
MISCONCEPTION OF THE DIESEL
FREIGHT INDUSTRY IN THE STATE.
THE FACT SHEET ASSOCIATE WITH
THIS BUILD FOCUSES ON THE
TAGLINE OF DITCHING DIRTY DIESEL
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA IN THE US
LEADER IN UPGRADING DIESEL
TECHNOLOGY.
FIRST OF ALL CURRENT AIRPORT
REGULATIONS REQUIRE THE
UPGRADING OF DIESEL ENGINES TO
REDUCE PARTICULATE MATTER.
AND KNOCKS EMISSIONS TO NEAR
ZERO EMISSIONS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IN ADDITION
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN NEW TRUCKS
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO MEET THE
STANDARD RESULTING IN INCREASED
EFFICIENCY.
AND CONCURRENT DECREASING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
RENEWABLE DIESEL.
FUEL.
WHICH REDUCES OVERALL FUEL
CONSUMPTION.
AND FURTHER CONTRIBUTES TO
FURTHER GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS OVERALL OVER OZONE
PRECURSOR EMISSIONS FROM DIESEL
ENGINES FROM THESE UPGRADES HAVE
RESULTED IN APPROXIMATELY NINETY
EIGHT REDUCTION PERCENT
REDUCTION OVER PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS OF DIESEL ENGINES.
CHAMBERS PARTICULAR CONCERN
ABOUT THIS BILL IN ITS GOALS
BECAUSE IT WILL DISCOURAGE
INVESTMENT IN HINDER
CALIFORNIA'S COMPETITIVENESS
WITH OTHER STATES.
RECENT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN A
CALIFORNIA IS AT A SIGNIFICANT
DISADVANTAGE OVER ITS SISTER
STATES IN THE AREAS OF
SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT AND
TRANSPORTATION OF GOODS.
AND CONTINUE CHANGES TO THE
DIESEL REGULATIONS OF BIG
DISCOURAGING INVESTMENT IN NEW
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE OLDEST SWEETS IN THE
NATION. FOR THESE REASONS
CALIFORNIA CAL CHAMBER
REPRESENTING FOURTEEN THOUSAND
MEMBER BUSINESSES WHO DEPEND
UPON RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION OF
GOODS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
NUMBER.
THERE'S AN OPPOSITION.
NO WELL KRAMER'S OF CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT I
DID WANT TO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
BILL.
OUR MEMBERS AND CALIFORNIA'S
FARMERS AND RANCHERS DEPEND ON
MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF DIESEL
VEHICLES TO PLANT AND HARVEST
AND BRING THEIR CROPS AND
LIVESTOCK TO MARKET.
AND WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE
USE OF INCENTIVES THE CHALLENGE
IS ONCE A REGULATION IS ADOPTED
THOSE ASCENT INCENTIVES ARE NO
LONGER AVAILABLE TO HELP
TRANSITION INTO NEWER CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY.
I AM WE APPRECIATE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE OTHERS OFFICE --
TALKING THROUGH THESE CONCERNS
WE APPRECIATE -- CONTINUING THAT
CONVERSATION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
AGRICULTURE ISN'T -- FURTHER
DISADVANTAGE AND THAT WE STILL
HAVE ACCESS TO THE VEHICLES THAT
WE NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THEN MR BETWEEN HER
BACK.
YES THANK YOU AGAIN TOM FORKS
DIESEL TECHNOLOGY FORUM AGAIN WE
REPRESENT MAKERS OF DIESEL
ENGINES TRUCKS LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES COMPONENTS.
IN LOW CARBON FUELS -- LIKE THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION YEA OR NAY ON THE BILL
IN FACT SOME OF THE THINGS THE
BILLS TRYING TO DO -- MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS SUPPORT MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY MEMBERS OF
CAL START AS WELL THEY'RE
SETTING UP SHOP THEY'RE WORKING
ON ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY VEHICLES.
IN MANY OF OUR MEMBERS IN FACT
HE DIESEL TECHNOLOGY FORM ALONG
WITH A LOT OF OTHER MEMBERS OF A
COALITION WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THE CLEAN AIR DIALOGUE PART
OF SEEDS ON GOING -- DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY HAVE ISSUED A
WHITE PAPER ABOUT LONG TERM
FUNDING FROM THE FOR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION INTERPHALANGEAL
PORT OF OF THOSE SORTS OF THINGS --
NOW WITH REGARD TO THE FINDINGS
OF THE BILL WE DO WANT TO LET
THE RECORD SHOW THAT.
IT THE THE FINDINGS WE FIND ALL
MET A LOT OF THE PROGRESS THAT
HAS BEEN MADE BY DIESEL ENGINES
IN BY THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS.
THE CHAMBER HAS GONE DOWN A LOT
OF THOSE ARE NOT GOING TO REPEAT
THOSE THINGS I DID WANT TO JUST
BRING BRING YOU TO THIS POINT.
OLDER DIESEL ENGINES ARE THE
PROBLEM AND EVERYBODY'S WORKING
TO GET OLDER DIESEL ENGINES OFF
THE ROAD.
THE LAST TEN YEARS EVERY NEW
DIESEL TRUCKS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVE THAT 98% KNOCKS
REDUCTION IN PM REDUCTION.
I ALSO WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT IT WOULD TAKE
MORE THAN SIXTY OLDER DIESEL
TRUCKS TO PRODUCE THE SAME
AMOUNT OF KNOX AND PM THAT ONE
NEW DIESEL TRUCK MAKES.
AND THEN LASTLY FROM THE HEALTH
EFFECTS INSTITUTE I DID WANT TO
MENTION THAT.
GIVEN PROPER AFTER TREATMENT
SYSTEMS THE HEALTH EFFECTS
INSTITUTE WITH THIS ASUS STUDY
FOUND THAT.
PM FILTERS AND ESSIE OUR SYSTEMS
GREATLY REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PM
FOR MODERN DIESEL ENGINES AND
THAT THE OVERALL TOXICITY OF
EXHAUST FROM MODERN DIESEL
ENGINES IS SIGNIFICANTLY
DECREASED.
COMPARED WITH THE TOXICITY OF
EMISSIONS FROM TRADITIONAL
TECHNOLOGY DIESEL ENGINES THESE
ARE THE OLDER DIESEL ENGINES WE
ALL AGREE LET'S GET RID OF THEM.
AND THEN FINALLY WITH REGARD TO
THE ROLE THAT LOW CARBON DIESEL
FUEL PLAYS WERE IT NOT FOR LOW
CARBON DIESEL FUELS THE SUCCESS
OF THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
WOULD NOT BE WHAT IT IS TODAY.
ON THE GASOLINE SIDE YOUR CAPPED
AT 10% PLANS BECAUSE OF THE
ETHANOL CONSTRAINTS WITH WITH
GASOLINE ENGINES SO ALL THE
GAMES FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
HAVE BEEN MADE WITH CARBON
REDUCTION CREDITING CREDIT
TRADING.
AS CALM AS A RESULT OF LOW
CARBON DIESEL ESPECIALLY.
RE REALLY LOW CARBON RENEWABLE
DIESEL SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE OPTICS OF THE BILL
DO NOT.
OVERLOOK THE GREAT PROGRESS IN
STRIDES THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
MADE.
IT'S A IT'S A LEGACY INDUSTRY
IT'S A HUNDRED YEARS OLD THE OF
MANY OF OUR MAKERS ARE STILL THE
ONES PRODUCING ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ELECTRIC CLASSY TRACTORS IN
MEDIUM DUTIES AS WELL.
SO AGAIN JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
FROM A TECHNOLOGY STANDPOINT WE
GET THE WHOLE PICTURE NOT JUST
THE BAD STUFF THANK YOU.
BY MATT RIEMANN WITHOUT MY
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION ALSO IN A
TWEENER NEUTRAL POSITION --
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE STAKE HOLDERS FOR SOME
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS ON THE
BILL.
AS CALIFORNIA MOVES TOWARDS NEAR
ZERO AND ZERO TECHNOLOGY WE ARE
GONNA NEED A MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE IN
ORDER TO HELP OUR FLEETS.
BE ABLE TO PLAN YEARS OUT -- WE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION MOVED FORWARD.
I NEITHER A TWEENER NORA --
OPPOSITION I APOLOGIZED TO ME
FOR BEING LATE A CHRISTMAS OUR
ON BEHALF OF OVER ON FUELS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU OKAY I OTHER FOLKS
HONOREES CONCERNS.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
THE ITEMS NOW FOR THE COMMITTEE --
CENTER CASKEY.
ARTHUR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING OUT THE 10% GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REQUIREMENT LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
GREENHOUSE GAS BUDGET AND STUFF --
TOO MY QUESTION IS ON THE REPORT
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO RELEASE WE
GOT A REPORT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
IT SORT OF UPDATE THESE MOBILE
SOURCES.
THEY IDENTIFY THINGS THEY TALKED
ABOUT TRUCKS THERE'S A REPAIR
BOARD HAS A STRATEGY ON TRUCKS --
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE WERE YOU
LOOKING FOR TO WITH THIS
LEGISLATION ON AD?
OTHER THAN THE REPORT COMING OUT
IN JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHAT A
TREAT YOUR MANSER THANK YOU SIR.
S. B. FORTY FOUR YOU'VE HEARD
SOME FOLKS -- IN OPPOSITION
REFERRED OPTICS.
MY PURPOSE IS SUBSTANTIVE IS NOT
JUST OPTICS -- FI OFFENDED SOME
WITH THE OPTICS APOLOGIES BUT
YES CALIFORNIA IS DOING A LOT
WITH LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
AND OTHERS.
TO HELP.
CLEAN UP THE THAT SECTOR BUT IF
WE LOOK AT THE SECTOR OF MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY AND IF WE LOOK AT
OUR INVESTMENTS.
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION FUND FOR
EXAMPLE.
IT IS FAR MORE HEAVILY WEIGHTED
TOWARDS PASSENGER VEHICLES.
NOW.
I DON'T WANT TO REDUCE OUR
INVESTMENT IN PASSENGER VEHICLES
THEY ARE STILL THERE'S MORE
PASSENGER VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
THEY ARE VERY POLLUTING.
BUT IF I LOOK AT THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR.
THEY ARE.
THE OWNERS OF THOSE VEHICLES NOT
IN ALL CASES BUT IN MANY CASES
BECAUSE THERE -- THEY TAKE A LOT
OF WHAT'S THE WORD THE ET THERE
ARE IT'S HARD ON THOSE VEHICLES
TO DO LONG HAUL AND ALL.
THE OWNERSHIP CHANGES MORE
FREQUENTLY.
AND SO BY PUTTING MORE
INVESTMENT TOWARDS OUR HEAVY AND
MEDIUM DUTY.
WE MAY.
GET.
MORE QUICKLY.
ACTS A CLEANER FUEL AND THAT'S
CLEANER AIR.
AND I DON'T WANT US FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE BEHIND CHINA.
HOW MANY ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS OR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES YOU KNOW
MEDIUM DUTY DO YOU SEE ON
CALIFORNIA ROADS NOT TOO MANY?
GO TO CHINA.
THERE ARE SEVEN TRUCKS.
THEY ARE MANUFACTURING THEM THEY
ARE.
USING THEM.
AND WHY SHOULD WE BEHIND
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF MANUFACTURERS RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO.
WHAT I ATE THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
EQUALLY?
DIRECTING OUR REGULATIONS AND
OUR RESOURCES TOWARDS THAT
SECTOR WHICH INDEED HI GOODS
MOVEMENT AREAS LIKE MY DISTRICT
WHERE THE PORT OF OAKLAND IS
WHERE THE PORT OF LA AND LONG
BEACH ARE.
AND THEN THROUGH THE I TEND IT
CETERA CORRIDORS HE WILL HELP US
CLEAN ARE HERE AND GET THOSE
CARBON REDUCTIONS [inaudible]
I THINK.
BECAUSE THERE'S TWO WAYS TO SKIN
THIS CAT AS I SEE AS THE STAFF
REPORT PARK.
**** OUT OR POINTS OUT IS THAT
YOU HAVE. 90% OF IF YOU BOUGHT A
NEW DIESEL TRUCK RIGHT NOW AND
YOU TOOK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR PETER BELT OFF THE OFF THE
ROAD THAT WOULD THAT WOULD DO
THAT THAT'S AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
GARCIA AT AB SIX SEVENTEEN HAS A
LOT OF CARL MORE YEAR FUNDS IN
THERE THAT GET SET THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION.
PUTTING MONEY INTO RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPING NEW TECHNOLOGIES ON A
CONTINUOUS BASIS BE THAT AS IT
IS THAT'S A THAT'S ANOTHER
STRATEGY.
AS I AM AS I'M READING THIS YOUR
ASKING THE AIRPORT TO TELL COME
UP WITH A STRATEGY NOT THAT
CHOOSE THIS STRATEGY -- THAT
STRATEGY THE BOTH STRATEGIES
RIGHT.
YES AND AGAIN TO THE CHAIR SO.
THE AIRPORT IS DOING A LOT.
BUT WE STILL HAVE.
THE DIRTIEST AIR OF ANYWHERE IN
THE US.
AND OUR SCIENTISTS ARE TELLING
US OUR WINDOW TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS VERY NARROW.
IF YOU'RE THE OPERATOR OF A OF
THESE LARGE DUTY THE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES IT IS NOT INEXPENSIVE
FOR YOU TO CONVERT.
I WANT THE STATE TO GIVE MORE
HELP TO THE OPERATORS TO CONVERT
AND I WANT THAT CONVERSION AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO BE IN A ZERO
EMISSION.
BUT I'M TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL ABOUT
THAT.
I HAVE NO PARTICULAR IT DOESN'T
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THIS ONE
OR THAT ONE IT'S JUST IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
TRANSITION.
LET SUPPORTED AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO ZERO EMISSION GIVEN.
WHAT WE ARE THE CHALLENGES WE
ARE FACING?
OKAY AND BY THE WAY I I I I KNOW
IT'S BEEN MISSED BEFORE I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE AUTHORS
AGREED TO REMOVE THE CONTINUES
CORPORATION.
AND ACTUALLY I NEED TO MAKE A
CLARIFICATION ON THE AMENDMENTS
I SAID I WOULD TAKE THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS WHICH I
AM HAPPY TO YOU.
BUT THE ANALYSIS FIVE IN THE
COMEDIAN I'VE TOGETHER BEEN
WORKING THE ON THE ONES THAT
WERE IN THE ANALYSIS OUR FIVE
WE'RE STILL REFINING EXACTLY THE
WORDING.
IT'S THIS IS NOT JUST MY DESIRE
TO MAKE IT -- TO TO REFINE IT
BUT BOTH THE STAFF AND MY STAFF
FOR WORKING SO THAT THE AMENDS
THAT.
I'M ACCEPTING IN THAT COME OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL REFLECT
THOSE AGREED UPON CHANGES
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MASTER.
WED ALWAYS TROUBLES ME WITH
THESE WHICH SERVER GREETING
CONCEPT AND CERTAINLY WE'RE ALL
SEEKING OUT WHAT YOU HAVE
ACTUALLY THE CONCEPT IS HERE A
BETTER AIR CLEANER AIR.
BUT WE GIVE IT TO CAR OUR AND
YOU SAID YOU KNOW SENATOR
SKINNER I HELP PLAN ON A FOR THE
US YOU JUST MADE A COMMENT THAT
WE HAVE THIS PLAN AND THAT PLAN
YOU WANT IT.
THIS PLANT THE BEST THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE THESE THESE PROPOSALS
THAT GOLD ARE SHOULD COME BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN TIME AFTER
TIME AND MANY ON MONTHS THAT
I'VE SERVED IN THIS COMMITTEE.
WE COME UP WITH WITH LIKE A
GREAT IDEA GIVEN TO OUR BUT IT
NEVER COMES BACK IN FACT THERE'S
BEEN QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER WE
REALLY HAVE ANY MEASUREMENTS.
THAT WE'RE GETTING WHERE WE WE
WANT TO BE SO I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I'D LIKE
YOU TO CONSIDER.
THAT GOING FORWARD AND I GUESS
ANYONE OF THESE BILLS LET'S PUT
THE LEGISLATURE BACK IN CHARGE
BECAUSE WE HAVE VERY -- BUS
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE PUBLIC AND
HOW IT IMPACTS THEM IN THE
COMPLAINT THAT I RECEIVED FROM
MY DISTRICT HAS THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN IN OUR KIND OF COME IN
AND THINGS ARE KIND OF DECIDED
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE TOLD US.
SO I AM GOING TO I'M NOT
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT I KNOW I AM
TOTALLY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU
DO AND YOUR PASSION TO DO THAT
BUT I DO BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD HAVE.
MORE OF A ROLE ON THESE BECAUSE
THEN WE CAN MAKE IT MORE
BIPARTISAN INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T LIKE IT IN
THE DEMOCRATS LIKE IT IN
SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN EVERYBODY
OUT THERE'S CONFUSE LIKE.
WHO LIKES IT AND WHO'S THAT
HELPING AND I DO BELIEVE WE
WANTED TO HELP EVERYBODY BECAUSE
HE'S A VERY VERY SERIOUS
ILLNESSES?
THAT WE KNOW THAT WE CAN RELATE
BACK TO THE POLLUTION THAT IS
SOFT INCREASED OVER OVER THE
YEARS SO WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
GOOD I MEAN WE CAN SEE THE
MOUNTAINS FROM WHERE I LIVE IN
IN THE OLD DAYS WE COULDN'T SO.
THINGS ARE HAPPENING THAT ARE
GOOD BUT LET'S PUT US -- LEASE
BACK IN SOME OF THE DRIVER'S
SEAT ON THINGS THAT REALLY
AFFECT AN INDUSTRY WE'VE HEARD
THAT A LOT OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE.
AREN'T WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT ARE ARE CON
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS THE THE
NEED.
THE OPPORTUNITY ON TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BUT THEY NEED MORE
INCENTIVES AND WE'RE THE ONES
SO THAT'S WHERE I AM ON THE
THANK YOU THE JOB [inaudible]
A CENSORED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR QUICKNESS ISSUE
FRONT CENTER AND TRY TO GET IT
ORGANIZED.
NOW TRY TO PUT A STRATEGY IT
TOGETHER THAT'S GOING TO BE.
TANGIBLE AND I DO AGREE THERE'S
NEED FOR CONTINUED OVERSIGHT
HERE BUT WE NEED TO BE VISIONARY.
TOO AND SO ONE THING I WAS
WONDERING I'D LOVE TO HEAR FROM
AMERICAN LONG POTENTIALLY ON
THIS.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COMPONENT OF
COURSE THERE'S A CLIMATE ELEMENT
STORY BEHIND THAT AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVEN'T GIVEN OURSELVES
I DON'T THINK MEANINGFUL METRICS
FOR HOW WE WANT TO ATTACK THINGS
LIKE CHILDHOOD ASTHMA.
IN A REALLY COMPREHENSIVE WAY
AND SO.
IN TERMS OF METRICS ARE
CONSIDERATIONS.
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER AS YOU GO
FORWARD MEAN.
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF TRUANCY
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AMONG
CHILDREN IS AS MUCH DO YOU IS
THAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE DATA
I BELIEVE THE THE THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION THE THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS.
DEFINITELY PUT THAT THAT OUT
THERE IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM ISM IN
CALIFORNIA'S DROUGHT LAST MONTH.
THAT EXACERBATE ASTHMA YOU'RE
ABLE I I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RIGHT TARGET IS RIGHT WE SAID
EMISSIONS TARGETS BUT WHAT'S A
TARGET FOR CUTTING THE RATES-CHILDHOOD ASTHMA AND HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY.
QUANTIFY THAT MEANINGFUL IMPACT
BECAUSE IF WE DO THAT NOT ONLY
WERE GONNA REDUCE HEALTHCARE
COSTS AS WELL BUT EIGHTY EIGHT
THERE'S ANY MORE KIDS IN A
CLASSROOM SO I I JUST WONDER AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
AND I'D LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
BY THE WAY AND ADDED ON BUT HE'S
TRYING TO WRESTLE WITH.
SOME MEANINGFUL TARGET IN THAT
WAY SO THAT WE DON'T GET TOO
LOST IN THE ESOTERIC SERVE YOU
KNOW.
WE WENT YOU KNOW 40% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY TWENTY
THIRTY RAIN AND THAT'S THAT THAT
MEANT THAT MATTERS TO THAT
SCIENCE BUT THERE'S ALSO
PEOPLE'S LIVES SO.
THERE IS SOME TO CONSIDER OF DO
YOU WANT TO CUT CHILDHOOD AS MEN
HALF BY ECSTASY THEY DO IT RIGHT.
WHERE DOES THAT GO SO SO MANY
CONSIDER?
EITHER FOR THE QUESTION STOPS
AND THAT THEY SENSE EMOTIONS.
OKAY A SPIRIT SPIRIT OF EMOTION.
WITH THAT THE AUTHOR MAY CLOSE --
THANK YOU APPRECIATE -- SENATOR --
STERN'S REFERENCES TO THE HEALTH
PART.
WHAT I OPENED WITH AND IT IS WHY
I AM FOCUSING ON PETROLEUM BASED
DIESEL BECAUSE OF THE
PARTICULATE MATTER ASPECT OF IT?
I DID TALK ABOUT OTHER EMISSIONS
BUT IT IS THE PARTICULATE MATTER
THAT IS THECONTRIBUTOR TO ASK
ME NOW IT IS NOT THE ONLY
CONTRIBUTED AS MUCH BUT IT'S SO
SIGNIFICANT.
AND IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT.
AND IF WE NOT ONLY IF WE DO A
BILL LIKE THIS BUT IF WE DIRECT
THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS TOWARDS
ASSISTING.
OUR HEAVY DUTY OPERATORS CONVERT
AS THEY PURCHASE THEIR FLEET
CONVERTED THE RIGHT KIND OF
VEHICLES.
THEN -- WE CAN ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE AND
I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR AND
SO MOTION BY CENTER STERN IF YOU
CAN COLOR ALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B..
FORTY FOUR THE MOTION IS D.
PASSES AMENDED TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ALAN I'M ALAN HI BATES.
BAIT SNOW HILL.
IL I SKINNER.
I SKINNER HI S. STERN.
TURN I STONE.
STONE NO BY CAL SKI.
MY CASKEY I OKAY SERVER
[inaudible]
IS.
I WOULD DO A MENTOR YEAH OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO THAT IS OUT THAT IS --
SEVEN FIVE TWO TWO THAT ITEM IS
OUT OKAY SO LET'S TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU SENATOR
RESERVATIONS.
LOSING COVERAGE YOU NEED AT TO
OPEN THE ROLE ON OUR VARIOUS
ITEMS -- LET'S START WITH THAT
NUMBER ONE COVER EURO THAT'S SP.
TWENTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
B. TWENTY FIVE D. PASSES AT THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE --
CHAIR VOTING.
CHAIRMAN YES DEVOTING I EPIX HI.
HI HILL [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN.
STERN NO.
AND THEN I HAVE TO TURN YOUR
SPIN OFF.
WITH ITS WITH THIS IS THAT OKAY.
WITH SECTION OKAY SO THAT'S A
FIVE TO I GOT -- TO FIVE TWO
THAT IS OUT.
BECAUSE THE ROLE IN THAT -- NEXT
IS -- THE MORALE BILL.
THIS -- ONE WE HAVE WE DON'T WE
CENTER BASES IS MOVING THAT.
THIS IS SB THREE EIGHTY FOUR WAS
PRESENTED FIRST.
I REMEMBER ONE SB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR ALAN NO ALAN NO BATES.
BATES I HILL.
HILL KNOWS SKINNER.
SKINNER KNOWS STERN.
TURNOS.
AND STONE.
DOWN HIGHWAY CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI NO.
OKAY SO THAT'S THIRTY TO FIVE
THAT -- ITEM IS THE FAIL SPOKE
WE WERE WONDERING
RECONSIDERATION.
OKAY GUY WE CONSIDER IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION GRANT --
OKAY ITEM THREE THIS IS THE
AMBER BILL S. B.. FOUR FIFTY I
WAS PRESENT BEFORE AT A QUORUM
SO WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
ROBERT THIS IS THAT WE CAN ASK
YOU -- COME ON BOARD A BILL
TODAY IT.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT THE MOTION-FROM ST WE CASKEY SERVICE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AS BEFORE.
FIFTEEN MOTION IS THE PASSES
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALAN HI
ALAN HI ACE.
BATES I HILL [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
SKINNER ICE STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE I WAKE OWSKI.
ACCOUNTS SKI I I MEAN SIX HERE
WHAT WILL WE WON'T BECAUSE I YET
SO THE SENATOR CAN CONTINUE TO
CONTEMPLATE.
I DON'T THINK THE BILL HAS ANY
REDDISH OPPOSITION -- WITHIN
MINUTES YEAH -- OKAY -- NEXT
ITEM IS SENATOR GLAZIERS -- SP.
SIX TWENTY ONE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB SIX TWENTY ONE THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTING HI IT IS. TWO ONE
SIX EIGHT HI HILL.
STILL A NICE DINNER.
S..
S. B..
SIXTY ONE CHAIRMAN AND I'D.
SKINNER ICE STERN.
STERN NO.
THESE WOMEN THAT'S CLOSE THAT'S
A FIVE TWO TWO I WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN THAT -- THERE BY THE WAY
WE LIVE MAKE SURE TO SHARE THEIR
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS WILL
SHARE WITH YOU CENTER SCARE.
FREE TO LOOK AT ON THAT YEAH
OKAY NEXT ITEM IS.
ITEM SIX IS COVER EUROS SP SIX
SIXTY NINE IT'S THE WATER -- ONE
YOU KNOW AS PART OF A BROADER
DISCUSSION ON WATER I GOT TO SAY
FOR THE RECORD THAT I TEND TO BE
MORE IN SUPPORT OF OF THE MINING
APPROACH BUT THIS IS GONNA BE A
LEADERSHIP PLACE WE ALL KNOW
THAT GEORGE SKELTON AT A GREAT
PIECE ABOUT THIS.
IN THE ONLY TIME THE ONLY THING
ON THIS BECAUSE I WAS.
OUT PRESENTING A BILL WHEN WHEN
THIS CLOSE BUT LET'S CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB SIX SIX
NINETY PASSED THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE ALLEN.
ALLEN I AM IN WACO SKI.
IN MY CASKET CHANGES NO TWO IN
HI.
MY CASKEY I TEMPORARILY.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO -- SHOULD WE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THE AMBERG BILL.
SENATOR.
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA CLOSE IT.
OKAY.
SO CLOSE THE BROWN EYES THAT
THAT -- THAT'S GOING TO CLOSE AS
A SIXTY ZERO VOTE -- SINISTER
AND STILL CONTEMPLATING.
AND JUST DELIVERING IT'S GOOD
IT'S GOOD DELIBERATIONS A GOOD
THING.
AND WITH THAT I I THINK OUR
BUSINESS HERE TODAY IS.
AT AN END I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THE VERY HARD WORK ON
THESE COMPLICATED BILLS.
STILL A LOT MORE WORK TO BE DONE
ON ALL OF THEM -- BUT WITH THAT
I'D LOVE.
TO ALL THIS MEETING ADJOURNED